good morning everyone it's being
nine o'clock we are going to begin the
public hearings
in criminal justice
i would ask that everyone rise and join
me in a pleasure
allegiance to the flag of the united
states
and with that i'm going to open the
public hearing on
what's the first one
hb 1460 1468 68 excuse me
thank you
the committee now calls sue hamola
representative pamola
did i pronounce that right
thank you
oh
i just got okay you're not the prime
very good
representative tony lebranch to
introduce the bill i apologize for the
confusion
sorry that was uh my bad
good morning criminal justice and public
safety committee i'm here on behalf of
the prime sponsor to introduce this bill
i'm a co-sponsor
uh
so i will first start off by explaining
the bill this simply removes cannabis
from all current rsas and therefore
legalizing it
in talking with other representatives i
believe the prime sponsor and i have
come to the conclusion that our there's
better bills than this one
especially the chairman's bill
so uh with that i asked the committee to
itl this bill thank you
thank you very much and we appreciate
that and so does the entire house thank
you
does anyone have any questions as a
sponsor uh representative true
thank you mr chair
um
what bill do you think is better than
legalized cannabis
which bill
so uh
thank you for the question um i support
legalization 100 and i've been working
with the chair on his bill i can't
remember the the bill number off the top
of my head but it's uh
representative abbas bill
thank you for the record that's house
bill 1598.
in addition we also passed one on the
house floor uh two weeks ago that fully
legalized i believe as well
thank you the witnesses uh excuse thank
you
the committee now calls representative
hamola
1468 that's it
hi thank you for um hearing testimony
today
uh i understand that the
one of the sponsors has just
requested itl but i i still would like
to express take about a few minutes to
express some some thoughts i have on
this bill on legalization in general
i was not able to attend the hearing on
the 20th of january due to being out of
town so i appreciate you giving me just
a few minutes today
um i also want to apologize
reading testimony is my least favorite
form of presenting but i'm operating out
for about three hours of sleep right now
so i'm just gonna i'm just gonna read
to make sure i don't miss anything
initially to oppose hpe 1460.
d8 to provide overall comments regarding
the legalization of cannabis
we are at the point where data is
available from other states to evaluate
how legalization has impacted their
respective areas
while some perceive new hampshire as
lagging in legalization as compared to
surrounding states i view this as an
opportunity to evaluate the effects of
legalization
and to avoid some of the most concerning
unintended consequences
in places like colorado and washington
where legalization has been underway for
some time we can see how it's playing
out
according to a variety of studies to
include a 2016 report by the rocky
mountain high intensity drug trafficking
area which is an agency
tasked with documenting the impact of
legalization in colorado here are some
of the results
cannabis related traffic deaths have
increased by 48 percent
youth marijuana use has increased by 20
percent in the two years following
legalization
cannabis related emergency room visits
nearly doubled two years after
legalization
child welfare related cases increased
after legalization
there was a marked increase in babies
being born with thc in their bloodstream
which primarily affected
communities of color and low-income
families
five years after cannabis sales began in
washington the number of accidental
ingestion of cannabis by young children
essentially tripled
and across the united states we can see
the effects as well uh as far as
childhood exposure to cannabis edibles
in 2016 those numbers were 187.
in 2020 the number rose to 3 000
annually
in a survey by the substance abuse and
mental health administration the results
detect uh detected a significant
increase in youth marijuana use in
legalized states
during a time when mental in mental
health indicators actually worsened
in our neighbor vermont the southwestern
vermont healthcare system
actually recently started reporting a
rise in cannabis related stomach
disorders this is due to the high thc
levels contained in today's cannabis
which then gets stored in body fat and
accumulates
until a patient experiences severe
abdominal pain persistence and sometimes
uncontrollable vomiting for up to a week
one of the other examples that we have
is oklahoma oklahoma actually does not
have legalized cannabis actually
oklahoma does it permits the use of
growing
and the use of medical marijuana
this is a little close to home for me
because
i moved here from oklahoma it was my
last one of our last military
assignments
i actually work as a hazard mitigation
planner in my day job and every day i
talk to county emergency managers in
oklahoma
one of the things that's happened there
is
overwhelmingly these emergency managers
are reporting the same issue
oklahoma's cannabis laws have attracted
a massive influx of organized crime into
their rural areas
some of the most rural areas now have a
definite definitive presence of russian
chinese and mexican cartels operating
farms under legal protections
worse yet many of these farms are
repeatedly sold multiple times a year at
top dollar
and most emergency managers recognize
and understand that this is just a legal
way for people to launder money for
these cartels then to launder money by
continually selling the same farm over
and over again to somebody else within
their organization
this actually happened to oklahoma
overnight
it has been shocking to them it's been
shocking to the emergency personnel
there at how fast the rural quiet areas
of oklahoma have been upturned
there are many unintended consequences
that accompany cannabis legalization
what is particularly concerning is that
if any proposal that calls for
legalization
18 years and above
there is still a well-documented
prolific information out there that
demonstrates negative effects of
repeated cannabi cannabis use on brain
function of young adults into their late
20s
and with that comes many negative mental
health consequences to include long-term
depression increased suicidal ideation
and increased
instances of mental health disorders
there's data out there it's it's just
fact
i know that there are individuals on
both sides of the political aisle here
in new hampshire who think that
legalization uh
of cannabis should happen because it's
already been legalized by our
neighboring states
part of the pro-legalization messaging
promises that cannabis will reduce drug
offenses be a tool for social justice
reduce black market selling and provide
a more regulated and safer product for
adult users the fact is that we're
already seeing the data coming out of
out of other states
not only is legalization not living up
to any of its promises
states who have legalized it are seeing
more unintended consequences that are
putting the majority of their citizens
at state
at stake
one of the things that's not in
testimony is that there is a gentleman
named robert
corey and he's a lawyer in colorado who
actually played a pivotal role in the
movement of legalizing marijuana there
he helped draft amendment 64 which
permitted the production and retail
sales of recreational cannabis in 2012.
he also designed and implemented their
dispensary framework and
for patients and caregivers under
amendment 20. he's a trial attorney he's
represented hundreds of clients accused
of
marijuana related offenses and he
litigated cases and administrative
actions involving amendment 64's
implementation
yet nearly a decade after colorado has
implemented
legalization
this is what a quote that he said in
this past year
i wish i could be proud of what we
created but i'm not
the outcome of 64 is shameful
hurts people in colorado is not safer
so i just want to leave us with this
thought
if you think that new hampshire should
legalize cannabis to emulate its
neighboring states
then we are not living up to our promise
of being independent thinkers
if you think we should legalize because
you feel it hap it will happen sooner or
later then we're seeding control of the
issue and ignoring the factual
information that has emerged from other
states
if we think we should legalize because
some adults want to use cannabis then we
are forgetting that our greatest
responsibility in life is to ensure the
health and safety of our children before
our own self-interest
if you think that we should legalize
cannabis just because it will put a few
more shekels in the general fund
than shame on us all
thank you
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony
is there anyone else wishing to testify
who didn't sign up
all right at that point then i will
close the public hearing on hp 1468.
and
we will be in recess until 9 45.
all right
having heard um various uh positive
sounds from the committee i'm gonna go
ahead and open the executive session on
hp 1468
and anyone wish to make a motion
representative connolly
and mr second
second by representative pratt
would you like to speak to your motion
mr vice chairman i believe the sponsor
who spoke said it pretty clearly enough
so
we can move on
very good
anyone else wishing to speak
representative true
thank you mr chair
um in the past i have said
on the house floor
um
and i'll repeat that for anyone who
missed it
i am a child of the 60s
and it was uh in fact 1973 before i
found out
the 60s were over
1468 house bill 1468 legalizes marijuana
i think that is a much
better approach
than other bills
that have uh
come to the floor
or come through through other committees
many other bills
earmark
millions of dollars
so that
the state can have
programs to help people who are abusing
the drugs the state is selling
that does not make any sense to me at
all
the state should not be involved
with selling
any more drugs than it already has
already is
house bill 1668
plain and simple
it's legal
leave people alone
if they want to smoke it fine if they
don't fine
i can't support the itl thank you mr
chair
seeing normal for further comments the
matter will now be put to a vote
secretary will call the vote
vice chairman roy
yes
representative lang
yes representative burt
yes representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
definitely yes
clerk votes yes representatives fellain
yes representative true
no
sorry no
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative panalakas yes
representative tallersky
yes
representative bordenay
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman yes
representative bolden
represent conley
yes
representative sue newman
representative bradley
chairman abbas
okay the vote is 16 years one nay
representative true will there be a
minority report
yes
anyone have any objection to consent
chair
i don't see any sense of it going on
consent
just wanted to ask
okay now the house will i mean excuse me
the
committee will stay in recess until 9
45.
okay it being 9 48 we're going to go
ahead and start the
public hearing
on
hb
1175 is now open
the committee now calls tony la branch
thank you
good morning again house criminal
justice and public safety committee my
name is representative tony lebranch and
i represent the town of amherst i come
before you today to introduce house bill
1175 and act relative to recording
interactions with public officials
this is a simple bill which adds a
single sentence to rsa
570-a colon 2 which is new hampshire's
wiretapping and eavesdropping statue
which makes it a crime to record others
without their express consent now we can
all agree
that makes sense no one should be
recorded without their express consent
especially because in new hampshire we
have a constitutional right to privacy
the issue with the current statute
is that similar statutes in other states
have been ruled unconstitutional by
multiple federal courts including
including the first circuit of appeals
in boston
the issue with the current statute is
that it does not make an exemption for
recording public officials which has
been ruled a constitutional right in
cases such as glick v cunniff
this bill would add that exemption to
statute and therefore make it
constitutional preventing the state and
local governments from unnecessary
lawsuits relating to constitutionality
of the existing statute
this bill has broad tripartisan support
and is a simple update to the existing
statute to make it conform to the first
circuit's decision in glick v conniff
and with that i asked that the committee
passed this bill with an ought to pass
motion
and i'm happy to answer any questions
um i have a question
so
by public officials um please give us a
definition of public official and you as
a as far as the bill goes
so
my definition of a public official would
be anybody who's employed by the state
uh state being any government in new
hampshire because i believe it's a
matter of transparency that
we know what they're doing with our tax
money what they're doing uh on behalf of
the people of new hampshire and i think
that it should be our constitution
constitutional right to record them
and if i allow myself a follow-up
um is there any notice requirement in
your bill in other words can you could a
member of the public walk up to one of
us on the street and secretly record a
conversation without letting us know
they were doing so
uh in this bill specifically thank you
for the question i'm simply just making
an exemption in the wiretapping statute
and not adding anything else in any
other statute it's just updating the
wiretapping statue because i know one of
my constituents was charged with this
statue when
they recorded their interaction with the
police on their own property they will
speak to that incident in
the next person speaking uh
but that is my understanding
representative panelakis
excuse my voice but
are you saying that if i go in a
grocery store and speak with one of my
constituents
about a bill or something that's going
on that they should be allowed to record
in
uh
thank you for the question uh this is
any uh employee
of any government in new hampshire
should be allowed to be recorded in this
bill
i believe they currently have that right
to record
representatives such as myself and
yourself
but this bill does not uh say anything
about giving notice i believe that would
have to be a separate bill this just
makes it not a class b felony felony or
a misdemeanor to do so
thank you
representative burt
thank you uh mr chairman and thank you
for uh your testimony and your bill i
wish my name was on it
uh
to
if i understand correctly uh what the
last speaker said if you could answer
yes or no on it i think in public
we can record
that is my understanding yes all right
follow up mr chairman yes all right
thank you
and what this bill does is it's
so i have my town clerk my chief of
police
if i go visit them during
their work day
this bill will allow me to videotape
them now if i go to their house
after their work day
the current law would still pertain and
i couldn't videotape them at that point
because they are off duty is that
correct that is correct and i will even
go further and just read the the simple
sentence that we're adding to this rsa
it just says a person
adding the exception to the current
wiretapping statute saying that a person
to record a public official in public
while the public official is in the
process of performing his or her duties
so it is only when they are on the clock
working for the state that they can be
recorded in public
and mr chairman one more last follow-up
you may thank you mr chairman and
i've talked to the aclu about putting
this bill in in the past i've talked to
about wiping out that provision
because in vermont where i came from we
can record single consent
they keep saying that this is the way to
keep it
for personal use but they do support at
that time i was wondering if you know if
they still support
doing this particular bill
thank you for the question uh it was my
understanding that they do support this
bill um
i don't believe anybody's here to
testify on their behalf but it is my
understanding that this
is supported by them yes all right thank
you
representative muse
thank you um if if the definition
actually includes all employees would it
include for example
someone like an active duty firefighter
in the process of actually fighting a
fire
my question is is there are
there are some
uh employees in in government whose
duties involve things that are hazardous
or dangerous
and having other people
get in the way of those activities can
actually put other people in danger
i'm just wondering if you could come
there would still be
able to have a corridor around a crime
scene or a fire it would just mean that
they could be recorded without fear of
prosecution under the existing statute
we see you know fires on the nightly
news on wmur but the wmur is not being
charged for violating that wiretapping
statute
so in that specific case i believe that
that right is already guaranteed that
they can record firefighters police
officers and other
public officials
without
being prosecuted for that
representative spelling
thank you mr chair and thank you to the
member for taking my question
um in the process of putting one of my
bills together for this session i had
spoken with a lot of parents who've had
interactions with dcyf
and i see this as a situation where
this would be extremely useful if
dcyf employees in the course of
interviewing parents whether in an
attorney's office or not could not
refuse to be recorded
and currently the situation is that a
lot of them are walking off and refusing
to do the interview until there's no
recording and
if it's not in an attorney's office we
run into potential complicated problems
if the parent insists on recording would
you say that this would solve that issue
i'm not sure i understand the question
dcyf is a is a public employee and this
would allow the parents being
interviewed to
legally record them in the process of
their duties which would be the
interview with the parents would it not
uh
in that specific circumstance i believe
that
they aren't exercising their public
duties and that anybody should be
allowed to record them in the process of
those duties thank you
representative gathering every catholic
thank you for taking my question
um so you would consider
yourself and all public officials or
elected officials as part of this
correct
thank you for the question
anybody that is employed by the state
and i as representatives we are
considered employees of the state so it
would apply to anybody that receives a
dime from
any state
or local government here in new
hampshire thank you
representative penalakis
thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question but you
expressed that it would be when they
were off duty like a police a fire or us
i don't ever think there's a time that
a police officer is off duty or a
legislator is off duty
so how would we get around that
thank you for the question
to the point about police officers there
is
you do punch out every day
and there is a time that you are off
duty of course you know
an off-duty cop could intervene in a
situation and if they see it fit you
know if they're in a convenience store
and it gets robbed they could
technically uh stop somebody but in that
case they're
usually in a public situation that's
already being recorded by convenience
store cameras uh so i
i don't see anything wrong in that
specific situation and for legislators
specifically i believe we already uh the
people already have a right to record us
at uh
when we're in the public that is the
the real important definition to see
here is that
if we're shopping at market basket or if
we're
you know doing our day-to-day duties
we're still being uh
we're in the public eye constantly and
they already have a constitutional right
to record us
thank you
representative
sorry i don't have you see your name
tallerski thank you
um according to how you just stated
anyone who is
employed by the state i assume then that
that it would extend to teachers
on every aspect of the day including bus
duty in the classroom coaching
extracurricular activities as advisor
even on field trip
uh
in thank you for the question in my
understanding of the bill that could be
a possibility uh
i hadn't thought about it but that is
definitely a possibility under this bill
elaine
sorry that was the exact question i had
i i was more concerned about a teacher
in a classroom and students being
recorded in the background and students
being involved and how would we deal
with that in in a teacher by this broad
broad bill which i agree with but i also
think there might be some unintended
consequences i'm trying to figure out
how we would deal with that and what
your opinion is of that
thank you for the question um
it could be amended as to excluding
schools
public schools
but i do not have any language that i
would amend it to at the moment that i
would be more than happy to find
sign language that would uh make that
exemption
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you
the committee now calls
looks like
lynn
osborne
anyone with a name even resembling
somebody from right to know new
hampshire
good morning
my name is lori ordolano i live in
nashua
i'm vice president for right to know new
hampshire and right to know new
hampshire supports this bill which would
allow a person to record interactions
with public officials in the furtherance
of their duties
installing video cameras in public
buildings has become commonplace
as it stands now for rsa 91a section 2
anyone just not local residents
must be permitted to attend a public
meeting and they can take notes tape
record take photos and videotape
the focus of my testimony is going to be
in public buildings
video recording employees performing
public duties in public areas would
allow the public access to information
to determine if records are being
handled correctly or if their treatment
is equitable it would permit a official
to be memorialized through video
our interpretation of public officials
would include public employees and
elected appointed officials
our interpretation of video recording
would include audio and video recording
the recording can only be done in public
spaces with people operating in the
furtherance of their official duties
municipalities can video record no audio
in public places without noticing the
public letting them know
i wondered if there's a legal obligation
to inform a person if they're being
videotaped in a public building and if
there's a statute that should be added
to the document if that exists i'm not
certain it does but that's one of my
questions
in december i just want to share with
you a personal experience
several years ago i started
investigating the assessing office in
nashua
and i just finished a trial in
my a right to know lawsuit suit that
went to court against the city of nashua
one of the claims was for video camera
security footage that was created in the
public customer service area of the
assessing office there were three
specific times and dates i wanted
this video camera
upon investigating the office the office
was set up the public service space with
a white board on the wall that would
show you when the assessor signed in and
out to go out and review properties
after i started questioning whether some
of one of our assessors was actually
performing those duties based on the
whiteboard the city removed the
whiteboard from the wall the very next
day they mounted a video camera in the
ceiling to video record public people in
this public space
in september
of 2019 i made a series of requests for
three pieces of film footage
i requested the recording because i
believed i was being treated differently
than other property owners coming into
an assessing office
and assessing a clerk assisting me at
the com customer service counter with a
verbal request to review property files
was disciplined by management for
helping me
and the employee was told we have you on
film
the employee was suspended for two days
without pay
for this
the requests were submitted starting in
september ninth and i didn't receive a
response back from the city for over two
months november thirteenth and the
response was a denial it took the city
two months to deny and the video despite
the fact that the city had a standing
policy
that no video would be released to the
public
i learned about this in my trial
and yet even though that was their
standing policy it took two months
the city denied the request by throwing
outrageous man if you could i apologize
for interrupting you could you stick to
the substance of the bill we don't want
to talk
nashua so much as we want this bill
to talk about the bill substance of the
bill
okay um
well the substance of the bill is based
on the fact that my request was denied
and i do with all due respect sir
i think it is relevant
i really do i think this is very
relevant i've given testimony for three
weeks up here and you were the first
person to say it wasn't relevant
that notwithstanding i am the chair and
i'm asking you to continue your
testimony but please limit it to the
bill and not your experiences with the
town of nashua at least the litigation
part you're free to tell us about how
the bill would help you
but
everything that happened after that is
not relevant to the bill
okay so i was denied based on five
exemptions
to see the video
exemption for internal personnel
practice exemption
9185 for confidential and financial
information
exemption for personnel and other files
whose disclosure would constitute an
invasion of privacy
exemption for records pertaining to the
preparation for carrying out all
emergency functions
and the murray exemption
for law enforcement compiling
information
in summary judgment the judge threw out
four of those out of the five
i'm waiting a ruling from the court
it was argued by my attorneys in
december and my position is if
municipalities can mount cameras
throughout public buildings and monitor
our interactions with employees
use those interactions to video
employees and citizens
use the video to discipline employees
and reprimand the public
citizens should be able to video record
our public system officials performing
their official duties
and on the record i would like to say
that when i spoke and said i was from
nashua i observed the share
look over to my two representatives and
i believe obviously you have a bias
about what i've done and you knew about
me
thank you very much i won't take any
questions
the witness is excused
the committee calls
ralph
wenberber
uh good morning members of the criminal
justice committee i'm here to speak in
support of house bill 1175 which adds
public officials to the exemptions
in the new hampshire wiretapping statute
this bill is intended to conform to
several rulings which conclude that it's
a violation of the first amendment to
prosecute somebody for gathering
information on an on-duty police officer
specifically
um but several other rulings in the
first circuit court of appeals have
extended that to public officials these
rulings include glick v cunniff martin v
evans and a more local one valentin v
city of manchester
um in 2019 i was charged with
wiretapping as a class b felony i
recorded an interaction i had with a
police officer who was trying to enter
my home and question me about a theft
report in the area at the time i was 14
years old and i refuse to let the
officer into my home or answer any
questions
thank you
um a few weeks later after uploading the
video online so i can send it to my
peers i had my phone taken by my school
resource officer without a warrant i
also had to forfeit my school laptop
once a warrant was granted the police
department changed my school password
having most of my assignments in a
locked school account this interrupted
my
digital school work
my attorney had tried to dismiss the
case cases violation of my
constitutional rights saying that higher
courts had already come to a conclusion
on this matter but the judge didn't take
it he said and i quote it doesn't matter
this is a statutory court not a
constitutional court and that's the line
that ultimately convinced me to pursue
this change um i reached in no prosecco
with the department and performed 20
hours of community service i spent that
time volunteering with school board
candidates
and the only real high school experience
i had before the kronos virus cam
pandemic was interrupted by a legal
battle and mandatory um
uh public or sorry community service
hours um just because i had exercised my
constitutional right to record an
on-duty police officer
uh you might recall hearing about the
similar arrest in march of 2015 uh
alfredo valentin a manchester resident
was charged under the same statute for
recording a police officer
um in 2017 the city of manchester paid
him
275 thousand dollars to settle the
lawsuit that he filed um i urge you to
recommend ought to pass on this bill and
to protect granite staters from
unconstitutional wiretapping charges
especially as police accountability and
general public official accountability
um has become an increasingly
an increasingly relevant topic in
everyday life
and to the points about
specifics with teachers and
representatives and supermarkets and on
the sidewalk
in the current language of the statute
it says that there has to be a
reasonable expectation of privacy for
this to be a charge so say if you were
at walmart shaw's on the sidewalk in a
classroom that wouldn't really apply
because i think that 30 high school
students or a few walmart customers
wouldn't really have a reasonable
expectation of privacy that's not a very
private
environment
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
would this bill help because i've seen
some students
get disciplined because there is a no
videotape
tape and policy in most schools
so would this bill help
because i've seen
when a student gets bullied
somebody else videotapes it and then it
goes up online
well if it makes national news
everybody's okay with it if it doesn't
make national news
then
the person being bullied is is going to
be in trouble
would this bill help that to stop
you know some of the bullying going on
in school because then it's legal to
videotape this or
maybe it wouldn't because it's not an
employee of
the state
um i'm under the impression that
recording policies within their own
district will be controlled by the
district but
um on like in the matter of the actual
law uh there wouldn't be a reasonable
expectation of privacy there and if
there was if there was only a few
students there then i don't think that
the student should be charged with
wiretapping or
um you know
disciplined by their school if they're
recording a bullying incident but that's
a case-by-case scenario all right thank
you
there'd be no further questions i
appreciate your testimony thank you very
much your excuse
is there anyone else wishing to testify
please bring your pink card up
the committee calls ian freeman thank
you
i am ian freeman i am a talk show host
uh host to talk program that's on 190
radio stations around the country so
freedom of speech freedom of the press
pretty important to me
and new hampshire has for a very long
time
been one of the worst states
when it comes to the wiretapping laws
here
i believe it's one of the three worst in
fact as far as people in new hampshire
generally do not have the freedom
to record a conversation to which they
are a party
without giving notice to all of the
people
who are involved
and this bill is not going to change
that per se but it does
do something very important and it does
allow people
to record conversations with so-called
public officials
um
my one concern with this bill and i
think it's a great bill is
as i read it it says a person to record
a public official in a public in public
while the public officials in the
process of performing his or her duties
having seen some of the prosecutions
that people have been brought up on
under this statute
i know that the courts the police
they tend to interpret this as strictly
as possible and in the favor of the
state
so when i see the word in public
it makes me think about a friend of mine
who called up a school official in the
city of manchester
and recorded the conversation
is a phone call with someone who's
probably sitting in their private office
private office right because you can't
just walk in
like you can walk into this room
they're a public official they're doing
their public duties but are they in
public
when they're on a phone call with you
well this guy was charged with felony
wiretapping as a result of simply
recording a phone call where he had a
few questions for this public official
in the school system of manchester and
he was found guilty
of doing that now ultimately the state
actually ended up mischarging him they
should have charged him with a wireta or
sorry with a misdemeanor because he was
a party to that call and so
there's like a distinction between
misdemeanor and felony anyway he got
charged for what should have been in my
opinion an on the record call so i my
concern with this bill is that it
shouldn't say in public it should simply
be anyone who is a public official
should be subject to being recorded
at any time when they're doing their
duties
so that's my one concern with this
having listened to some of the questions
up here
i don't think there should be a notice
requirement in general to
record anyone
and if you think about it
certain people who are
let's say less than honest or not
trustworthy as some of the government
workers can be
will change their behavior
based on whether or not they know
they're being recorded
so
in other states
if you are you know wearing a hidden
camera or hidden audio recording device
you can go in and go into a car shop
that you know has been accused of doing
dastardly things they're doing
repairs that aren't called for or
they're doing something that's untoward
and you can record them without their
knowledge
and see what they do
maybe they're going to do something
wrong maybe they're going to be
dishonest whereas if you walk in with
the video camera openly
they know you're recording they're going
to change their behavior and so it's
important to be able to record people
without their knowledge
which is it again this bill doesn't
address that but i'm explaining one of
the big differences between new
hampshire and almost every other state
in every other state as long as one
person knows there's a recording
so if i'm the undercover recorder i'm
the person who knows there's recording
it's legal in new hampshire that's a
crime
and so that means that we cannot hold
public officials
accountable
this changes that at the very least for
public officials it still allows other
private people to to not be held
accountable so again the statute still
has
serious problems even with this change
but i do support this change because uh
if you've read the new hampshire
constitution you know that the bill of
rights
article 8 does specify that government
here is supposed to be open and
accountable if you cannot record
a public official without their
knowledge in the process of their duties
if they're on the up and up and they're
doing the right thing they should have
nothing to be afraid of so i support
this bill
and i really appreciate your time happy
to answer any questions
i'm going to recognize myself for a
question what are your thoughts on the
on the school part of it we heard
questions about regarding you know
guidance counselors and things of this
nature while they're talking to students
and in the classrooms where
minors might be picked up on the
recordings etc
yeah i fully support the right of
students to be able to record any
interactions
with any of the public officials at the
schools these people are are paid by the
state and they should have no special
rights no more than anyone else so if
and it's certainly true that there are
some teachers that are doing abusive
things in their classrooms uh that
they're you know doing things that they
shouldn't be doing and i think that this
could hold them accountable for that i
guess the the crux of my question was is
with regard to um
with regard to other students in the
classroom being recorded
um who aren't public officials in the
process of recording the public official
in a classroom what are your thoughts on
that run that by me one more time so if
i'm gonna i'm a student and i want to
record my math teacher because he's
doing whatever yeah i'm also going to be
recording my classmates who are not
public officials and who are minors and
who have not signed a release to allow
themselves to be recorded what are your
thoughts on that this is the right i see
what you're saying here um
in my opinion if you were in a public
place you're subject to being recorded
if i go down to
the park and i want to record what's
going on in the park it's my right to do
that personally i wouldn't because i
think that's boring and it's not you
know something i'm interested in but if
you're in public you don't have a right
to privacy and if you're in a public
school classroom you don't have a right
to privacy so
if that's a concern for some kids they
shouldn't be going to government school
and they should find a private school or
go and be homeschooled where they'll
probably get a better education anyway
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
uh with the school's situation
i have
some
friends that are parents of high school
kids and they're always complaining
about the tick tocks that they're
constantly recording in schools
and if i understand right they're
picking up
kids in the background
in a public setting like that
you don't need consent do you from
you know all the people around you
the statute as i'm familiar with it and
it is you know a lengthy statute
is
nebulous in general about what consent
so i'm of the belief that if you're in a
public place and you're obviously
recording
if you continue to speak to me you're
consenting however i don't know if the
courts would interpret it that way
that's just my belief as somebody who
believes in in freedom of speech like if
i if we're having a conversation in a
park and i pull a camera out you should
presume i'm going i'm i am recording you
and if you keep talking you should
presume
that that's going to be recorded so in
my mind you're continuing to have that
conversation
is is your consent to being recorded but
i don't know if that's ever really been
addressed in the courts and given the
the way the statute is written about all
parties must consent
it's not all parties who need to be
noticed if i recall i don't have it in
front of me at the moment
but the way it's written is not very
good and new hampshire is one of the
least free states when it comes to this
thank you
representative board name
thank you mr chair uh thank you for
taking my question sure
so if this law or this bill became law
there would be no privileged uh
space for public officials and that is
including
courts of law including
grand juries where
we
keep witnesses separated their testimony
separate from each other until they have
testified
and a recording of their testimony
could be exposed to
witnesses in the future
to reflect to uh
have influence on their testimony uh
is that a concern
are you saying that grand juries are
public officials meaning that it's open
to the public because my understanding
you cannot go into a grand jury i cannot
just walk in as a member of the media to
record a grand jury um
hearing
i'm uncertain whether it's a public
space but it's i'm telling you it's not
thank you
representative conley
thank you mr chairman and thank you to
the witness for taking the question new
hampshire is a state that values its
freedom undoubtedly
we are also a state that
gives individual that values individual
privacy
the way this is written
i don't know what percentage but vast
swaths of our state i you could say half
of our residents would qualify under
this
as a public
person who could be recorded in their
everyday duties in their everyday life
i guess i'm wondering does that concern
you does that
do we have do we
cede our right to
limited privacy by virtue of running for
a water board seat or getting a paycheck
from the government
i think you're overestimating the
numbers of people that are considered
public officials this only addresses
public officials those are people who
are being paid who have sworn some sort
of an oath
to
perform a duty for the state i don't
think half of the people of new
hampshire qualify for that it's probably
less than a tenth
would be my guess but to answer your
further question yes
if you are a public official if you have
any kind of job where you're working for
the state you should be open and
accountable and that means that you
should be able to be recorded in the
process of your duties
that's part of the deal when you take
this position
as people get to record you doing what
you do
it's not part of the current deal but
thank you that is the way it should be
representative spelling i'm sorry just
may i go on a little bit
you can be recorded right here right now
without your consent you can be recorded
walking through the hallways without
your consent it's just the question is
should you be able to be recorded
without knowing
and i think you should
representative colleen
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question from
your perspective where does the
reasonable expectation of privacy come
in because a lot of the discussion i'm
hearing
they're talking about
recording people in essentially public
places which there is no reasonable
expectation of privacy and i would
imagine that under current law they
couldn't be charged anyway for example
when videos are done of the protests in
front of the state house they don't get
a waiver from every single person
attending the protest that's right
because there's no reasonable
expectation of privacy attending a
protest in the front of the state house
for the same token what you just said
about walking down the hallway here
there's no reasonable expectation of
privacy anywhere walking down a public
room there would be a reasonable
expectation of privacy in one of the
side offices having a discussion with
somebody one-on-one
but not
in a hallway or in this room
so where exactly
is the reasonable expectation of privacy
and this law or this bill that could
become a law
um
intersecting can we kind of separate out
what this is actually doing compared to
what some of these other questions are
that
really don't apply because it's already
got no reasonable expectation of privacy
i see what you're saying i think this
bill would allow those conversations
that you're talking about whether it be
with a dcyf official police officer or
whoever it is that's having that
conversation
in a quote-unquote private room there's
still a public official doing their
public duties and that's why my concern
is that there is this line of in public
in this this bill which i think should
be struck
because the courts are always
interpreting this as strictly as
possible and if you're a public duty i
don't care if you're in your office or
if you're on a phone call
you are getting paid by the state and
you should be held accountable for that
so this would increase the ability to
record government people wherever they
happen to be
follow-up
thank you mr chair
i agree with you about the public
statement because when i read that that
might become a problem if
parents allow dcyf into their home and
they record the interaction their home
is obviously not public that's right
so
would you
think that this bill would be
sufficient enough
as is with the removal of the word
public i think it's an excellent
improvement if you were to i think it's
fine as is but it would be even better
removing that word uh in public those
two words from this bill
i think it would be absolutely fantastic
for accountability of government
representative newman
you can't see the dean of the house she
has her hand up i'll defer to the dean
of the house and then ask my question
later okay representatives
i i seem to
think thank you for taking my question
but i seem to
think that listening to you
that you are saying
that when you
take a job or run for an office in the
state of new hampshire
you
lose your freedom of speech
no ma'am that's not what i'm saying at
all i'm saying you lose any kind of
ability to have or you should
you should lose your ability to be
private as a public official meaning
that you should be free to say whatever
you want
i should be free to record you saying
whatever you want as a public official
does that make sense
what part
okay thank you
representative newman
thank you
and thank you for taking my question
sure
just listen to the testimony there's a
lot of confusion about definitions
there's a lot of community confusion
about exemptions there was testimony
earlier that listed a list of exemptions
and and that's just the way that these
laws are written and presented when
they're heard in the public hearing
so
i'm having a lot of trouble with
definitions of public definitions of
public official i mean you have one we
all have different ones sure and i
suspect that there are definitions in
other parts of the law
so just for my question
we assume as the bill is written that
says in public space public places
um
do you think that in in this building
there are spaces that other than the
men's and ladies rooms
that are private spaces where the public
does not have access to those spaces and
and does should not expect
the ability to record things in those
spaces in a public building
that are did you just agree with that
concept either or other or not you may
say there are none of them yeah i don't
think this bill pretends to actually
give
people access to locked off areas or
something like that so
i as a member of the media can't all of
a sudden go into your whatever private
area you might have with other state
reps i don't even know probably exists
but if i did know it existed if the door
is locked and it's authorized only or
something like that so this doesn't open
up uh closed public or closed spaces as
i understand it and forgive me the
definition of public spaces and private
spaces and public buildings is probably
defined somewhere in the law and maybe i
hope we get to look that up when we
before we execute but
so my other question is
like the school we talked about schools
and the public cannot just walk into a
school and walk down the corridor and
walk into a classroom when the school is
in session that's right so i i wonder if
if you would find that to be
a public space
as as it is in this bill or or when you
think we should be recorded probably
everywhere but that's okay
do you think there are spaces like that
that the public work areas uh there are
a lot of places that the public cannot
just walk into so i i don't know if you
agree with that definition or not
yeah i see where you're coming from and
again i don't think this bill addresses
what is and what is not a public space i
don't think it opens any previously
restricted spaces there obviously
places that are government places
whether it be a jail or a school or
whatever where you have to pass some
sort of
rigorous examination in order to get
into that place
if you are into that place if you have
been authorized to go into that place
i think that you should be able to
record anything that goes on in that in
that facility whether you be a student a
visiting teacher or whoever you happen
to be
very much for that question for that
answer i have what i hope is a simple
question if i'm sitting at a at a
restaurant with my child
and they ask me dad what's going on in
the state house and i sit and have a
conversation between me and my child to
educate them on what's going on should i
be able to be recorded by doing that by
your child you mean
by anybody should somebody be able to
walk up and stick a
camera in my face while i'm just having
a dinner conversation with my child
is that because i'm a public official i
give up that right to have a free
conversation with my child you're in a
private business at that point and i
think that the business owner would be
the one who gets to decide whether or
not people get to record in their
property as a member of the media i
am uncomfortable i generally
decline recording when i'm in private
businesses unless there's something
absolutely outrageous that like if
somebody gets attacked right like then
okay i'm gonna pull out a camera and
record that uh but uh just you know the
normal pro procedure of business i'm not
interested in recording that without the
permission of the the business owner
typically because i do respect the idea
of private places so i guess that would
come down to the question of is a
private business considered a public
space i would say it isn't even though
you could argue that it's open to the
public
and again that would come down to where
if anywhere is this defined
the idea of a public space is a private
business considered a public space under
the law i'm not sure
i don't consider it to be a public space
personally
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so i do i do
recognize that your your back is is up
pretty straight on this and you're
taking a really really firm stance
my question
is more of unintended consequences so
you made this statement that most
government officials are crooked
so you you did no you said he said
something untrustworthy okay so
so
i also would have to say that a lot of
regular citizens are untrustworthy we
have a huge human trafficking
child pornography it's a problem it's a
big problem so i know in most schools
every every parent has to sign a release
even if there's a parade before they can
put a picture of any child even on their
on their
their website any kind of social media
there has to be a release signed so are
you saying
that if somebody wants to go into the
school and record
all these innocent children that are
sitting there
have the right to be recorded because
their parents are choosing to send them
to that school
if there are people in that school their
fellow students who want to record then
yes they should be able to record their
fellow friends
and classmates
in public
that's what i'm saying
and
if you want privacy
it's fine
i'm going to continue my answer
uh if
okay
if you want privacy ma'am
you
are responsible for that so you need to
close your blinds you need to stay
inside your home and never leave because
every time you leave your home you are
being recorded likely there are cameras
everywhere whether it's you or your
children or whatever whether it's
walking into walmart or the airport or
just driving down the roads there's a
good chance there are cameras pointed in
your direction that is the society that
we live in so if that's concerning to
you
put on a mask put on a hoodie point of
order okay
let's represent the witness will suspend
um
there being no further questions
witnesses excused
uh there being no one else wishing to
speak the public hearing on this bill is
closed
at this time we will open the public
hearing on hp 1571.
the committee calls representative
dennis thompson
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for hearing me this morning
i'm presenting this bill for its prime
sponsor representative tim egan he's
unable to be here today
he has business in another part of the
state
i'm not sure how many questions i can
ask answer for you but i'd be happy to
try
he's given me a statement that he'd like
read
hb 1571 relative to increasing fines for
littering and direct revenues
directing revenues to the fish and game
department is a bill that's important to
protecting our environment supporting
our valuable tourism economy
fortifying our conservation officers
staffing and supporting our
under-resourced fish and game department
i think we can all agree that enforcing
fines has a value
an increase in fines means we're taking
matters very seriously
the threat of fines helps visitors want
to keep the roads and parks pristine
by forcing folks
to keep our highways byways and
attractions clean
it safeguards our tourism economy
we need to support the funding of for
the fish and game officers who catch
poachers monitor hunters save lost
hikers pride themselves on studying
new hampshire flora and fauna and
support is shown in the percentage of
the fine that's going to help to hire
new cos
conservation officers
how does the harsh
littering finds benefit our society and
save new hampshire residents money
it improves community feeling and
economic impact people want to populate
attractions
but they want to populate clean
attractions a cleaner community draws
tourists than their tourism dollars a
fine is a deterrent to those who who can
easily dissolve
devolve i apologize from littering or
illegal dumping and litter pickup by the
new hampshire d.o.t
is
labor-intensive and cost
costs a tremendous amount of money to
the state taxpayers
i want to thank you for considering this
bill and i believe it'll have a
tremendous impact
take any questions
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
if you know because i definitely don't
um do you know how much money is
collected each year in
new hampshire from littering fines and
then
where is that money going right now so
you know if we're taking 20 here we're
gonna steal it from somewheres so what
is being removed
i i don't know i assume that the
majority of the money goes to the
highway department
um because they're the ones that have to
deal with that
um
what what uh
representative egan is asking for is
that twenty percent of any fines as they
be increased and that twenty percent of
those fines be diverted to the fishing
game
um for training and for acquiring new
officers
you may or may not know that fishing
game is very
tight on how many personnel they
currently have in the field
and
we need to find a way to fund that this
is not the only way but it's one way
that would help yeah thank you
representative boardney
thank you mr
thank you for taking my question
um
i have a problem with
the way this bill is worded it says it
will increase the fine for violations of
this section by 20 percent
most times when we look at fines they're
expressed as monetary amounts rather
than an increase
is that a problem
it just so happens that i also sit on
transportation and public works and
highways
and yesterday we had a bill
which proposes to increase the fines for
littering dramatically over what they
were
i think a first offense a violation was
64.50 initially and the new bill would
raise that to 300 dollars for first
offense and 500 dollars for second
offense
so it would add 20 percent to those
which would create
a substantial amount of money for fish
and game
um also for the state
wherever that money goes i don't know if
it goes to the judiciary or if it goes
to
to public works and highways but uh 20
percent of it would be diverted through
a fund
under rsa 206
and that really is what i can tell you
that bill is still in committee
and i can't tell you whether it'll pass
or not but
currently i can tell you that first
offense is 64
50 the second offense is 129 dollars i
believe
and
if i might add something else
i'm from coast district one
and
the biggest problem we have with
littering in coast district one is in
our trail systems
and the reason it's such an intense
problem is because the people who own
those lands
and allow the
the people to recreate on them um well i
had one stop at my office one couple
they had walked one day
when the ohrvs were on there and they
came out with two five gallon bottles
buckets of beer bottles
i don't know how
we can stop all that but if we can make
the fines
so relevant to people's
personal economy that i think that's
going to help
so
if we were to make this a uh follow-up
yes
thank you um
if we were to make this a monetary fine
what would the fine you suggest
well it's twenty percent of whatever the
fine sorry i am in law at twenty percent
i i don't think that means anything to
me um well in a 500 fine it would be
is that what you said 600
at that point
plus penalty assessment
okay thank you
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony thank you very much
the committee now calls richard head
from new hampshire
judicial branch
now
morning mr chairman my name is richard
head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch we
have no position on the policy of this
bill there were two things i wanted to
briefly discuss
one is something it's also in your in
the electronic filing of the of
testimony relates to the effective date
one of the things i'm doing this this
session is
sort of going to every bill that has an
issue relative to the effective date of
bills
um because it's important to the
judicial branch so i did want to take
just a minute to briefly explain why it
is
um that we are doing this and what the
what the concern is and and what i've
handed out is the is the letter of
testimony and then on the back side of
that is is the proposed amendment on the
effective date
and and this relates to a statute which
is rsa 14 colon 9a which talks about um
which is a statute that actually defines
when an effective date of a bill should
should apply or what it should be
and what it says is that
each law that affects judicial practice
and procedure or establishes or
eliminates criminal prohibitions civil
causes of actions or remedies or
limitations of actions shall take effect
on january 1 of the following year
and the reason for that is and i can use
this bill as an example
this bill
in in several different
sections of the statutes
would have a
modification to the fine schedules and
would require the judicial branch to
distribute those monies differently than
we currently do
so what that means is that when a clerk
is receiving money at a courthouse
that money has to be inputted into our
system in a particular way
so that this specific line of statute
is also has a core
corresponding line in our odyssey
database and that the odyssey database
has a code that tells our financial
people
20 of this fine has to go to in a
particular location that takes time so
this bill impacts three different
statutory provisions those three
provisions have to be updated
and there are statutes or bills after
bills after bills that do the exact same
thing
they change uh felony provisions they
exchange civil provisions and it just
takes us time to get all those lined up
so that's the the reason behind this
statue it's a long explanation but i
like to explain it to big committees
because all of you are also proposing
bills and i do ask if you were proposing
a bill that that does any of these
things if you could make it january 1
you won't have to hear from me so often
so i try to give you an incentive to do
that also
um so i do ask and and i've proposed the
amendment on the back side of what i
handed out today simply changing if this
bill were to go forward simply change
the effective date to january 1 of
2023.
um and then i would also be happy to
answer any questions i did do at least
the judicial branch's fiscal note um on
this i'd be happy to answer any
questions if you had any regarding the
the fiscal note uh would that be
that's all i had
representative conley thank you mr
chairman thank you mr head for taking
the question can you clarify where
fish and game or where littering fines
currently go
uh
in our state sure thank you so and what
i have are the three
statutory sections that are specifically
referenced in this bill
so rsa 265 colon 102
that goes to the highway fund
rsa
163b is goes to the general fund
and rsa 163 b3s both are the one 163bs
those are both general fund
distributions
and what this would do
under the new bill or under the proposed
bill would be
an additional amount
that would go to
the
new fund that's created through the bill
the same amount of money would be
distributed to the highway fund or the
general fund because it's only the
additional 20 percent that gets
sent to the new fund at least that's how
we read the statute or the bill
in addition there is on all fines a
penalty assessment and that penalty
assessment is distributed separately
through a different statutory provision
in the the split on penalty assessment
funds are general fund uh victim
assistance fund and the judicial
branches branch's
it fund
is is the breakup and the percentages on
those and i
i don't have the exact percentages of
those uh the penalty assessment
distributions but those are the three
ways it gets distributed
representative splain
thank you mr chair thank you mr head for
taking my question um over here
right there
it's hard to hear but i got these things
and i got to find yeah i understand um
can you tell me if uh dumping on private
or public land and or industrial dumping
falls under the same category as
littering
because it seems to me that
a better
direction for
money for fishing game would be those
high impact areas of
illegally dumping
large quantities of materials on those
back dirt roads and and field trails and
such that actually impact those of us
who go out hunting
and
i think are more easily tracked down to
the owner who dumped in a lot of cases
because there's some identifiable
information that's been dumped there
rather than littering on the side of the
road where previously we heard about the
person who brought in two things full of
beer bottles
unless you catch them in the act you
can't get that money so i'm wondering if
that's considered still littering or if
there's a different statute that that
deals with illegal dumping on purse
private land public land and then
businesses who do so
um short answer is i don't know um a
slightly longer answer is not based on
my experience in the judicial branch my
experience in private practice
i think you might also implicate some of
the
solid waste or hazardous waste statutes
in the department of environmental
services
depending on what the material is
and the quantity but you may have some
environmental statutes that deal with
solid waste
or hazardous materials that that would
apply in in a larger dumping situation
you also have some that relate to tires
and other things
thank
you
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you sir for
taking my question thank you
just look around you you'll find you'll
find the voice sooner or later i gotta
look for the little red light um
let's see where was i going uh
i don't recall you
here last year
with this
maybe you were and i wasn't paying
attention is this a new find that your
the dates is that is that a new push for
your office
yes and no so i started about
in about a year ago uh howie zibble had
the position before before me
um i don't know what how he was doing
unfortunately last year when i started i
was doing everything remotely
because at the time those hearings were
all being remote
i did try to do it as much as i could
last session this session i'm probably a
little bit more active in in the effort
only because
um you know we do see it a lot it does
have actually a substantial impact on
the individuals who are who are trying
to do all this we see it especially in
the
criminal penalty sections
which has a whole
whole area of of
recording requirements so for example
any modification to a criminal statute
you're implicating the j-1 system the
uniform charge table which the
department of safety and the department
of justice have to line up so that when
a
law enforcement officer
is filing a charge that charge
corresponds to the current version of
the statutory provision and then
corresponds to the proper penalties and
any time you make a tweak in a statute
j1 has to get changed the uniform charge
table has to be changed and then within
the department or within the judicial
branch
our odyssey
database has to be changed so when that
is received
our databases identify it with the
current language of the statute as as
it's been modified in the legislative
session
and the appropriate penalty whether it
be a violation misdemeanor or a felony
and because there are so many even the
slightest modifications that occur all
of our all of those lines have to be
accurately reflected in both the
what law enforcement sees under the
uniform charge table and then what the
judicial branch sees in our odyssey
database to ensure
that
there are no errors at the time a
charging document is filed with us
follow-up
thank you mr chair thank you
i was pre-med not pre-law but i i
understand why you need that extra time
in the past if you didn't have that
extra time
what happened say if this bill went
through and nobody caught
that is effective in 60 days
what would happen
so i i don't know based on personal
experience i don't know if mistakes were
being made and documents had to be
modified once something got filed or if
money was being sent to the wrong
location for a period of time i don't
know the answer to that but it certainly
increases the likelihood of errors being
made if those systems aren't up to date
thank you very much thank you for the
question representative analakas
thank you mr chairman would you have any
idea mr head of how much money we take
in per year
um so the
it's it's
there are two areas in which the money
can come in so i only have the judicial
branches some of it is paid directly to
the agency
um
in so we we took um
2020 data
um
and in 2020
actually we took essentially from from
november 1 2020 through
october 31 2021 so when i put the note
together
the total
collected under the three funds was
a little over nine thousand dollars
so the additional twenty percent if you
just take that would be about an
additional eighteen hundred dollars
based on what we collected
and then i think the
um
at least the fiscal note that combines
both our fiscal note in the department
of safety's
suggests that the total additional
revenue would be less than five thousand
dollars per year
thank you very much
there being no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you is
there anyone else wishing to testify who
hasn't signed up on this bill
seeing none i will hereby close the
public hearing
on hp
1571 fn
and the committee will stand in recess
until 11 15.
sorry
you know what i thought
is
i was just trying to look it up
so
um
i don't know
thank you
um
that one way
uh
okay
it's oh someone walking down the street
foreign
thank you
up
it being 11 15
we will now be opening the public
hearing on hb
1108 relative to the prescribed mana for
posting public land
the committee now calls ellen reed
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable members for welcoming me to
your committee uh for the record my name
is ellen reed i represent rockingham 17.
new market and new fields
this short bill before you all it does
is provide an alternative method
of posting one's land for property
owners
it does not provide an incentive or
decentralized posting it just provides
an alternative method it doesn't remove
the current method
now why would we need this well the
current law prescribes the method of
posting as putting a sign with lettering
that's a certain number of inches tall
two inches tall
says that the
landowner's personal information contact
information must be on the sign it has
to be every hundred yards but there's a
few problems with this method of posting
and this is something that many other
states which i'll get into in a moment
have identified
mainly that signs are not
rugged when it comes to weather when it
comes to animals when it comes to even
people possibly tampering with signs
signs typically only last a couple years
also they tend to be more expensive
and more difficult to put up on trees
and they damage because the nail holes
damage valuable butt logs which are the
most valuable logs when you're lumbering
damage that lumber
so
the easier cheaper faster method
especially if the landowner happens to
be elderly or disabled and has a problem
getting up and hammering signs into
trees the easier method is simply to
spray a vertical line of paint this is
something that some 20 other states have
already done a handful of states have
current open legislation on
and so that is what this bill does it
mimics the language that is pretty much
uniform across the country
and just so you know the states that
have adopted this are typically big
landowner rights states like texas
louisiana kansas idaho florida
pennsylvania tennessee montana passed
this in 1973
and arkansas has been doing this since
so it's a well understood uh
non-problematic way of posting land
so
there are a a few
questions or concerns that i've heard
when discussing this bill with um
interested parties in general most
landowners seem very favorable but
favorable to this
but i want to address
the
questions that i've heard so the first
question is could does this have the
potential to cause confusion in terms of
the idea that there's trail markings out
there that might look like this there
are no standardized systems of trail
markings that involve vertical paint
stripes purple paint stripes um
usually and you may know this from
hiking in our state parks
trail markers usually
involve specific shapes and specific
colors not just a vertical paint stripe
usually on signage
also the question has been raised as to
whether or not this could impact people
who are colorblind and would they be
able to see the markings red green color
blindness means that if in the worst
example you would not be able to
distinguish purple from blue certainly
if you are colorblind you know that
purple and blue look the same to you and
this would be obviously a painted mark
on a tree that looked like what you know
as purple
or blue which are the same to you so
this is a very obvious it doesn't look
for a colorblind person a stripe of
purple does not look like the tree it
doesn't look like the bark it looks like
a paint of a painted stripe of blue
which is very obvious to that person in
addition i would argue that frequently
not always but frequently people who are
out there
and hunting is the most frequent example
of someone who might be out there
looking for
no trespassing signs
that frequently they're not alone so
certainly they can confirm with someone
else that they are with but i digress
another argument i've heard or an idea
i've heard is well what happens when the
property is sold and new landowner
doesn't necessarily want to post their
land
much like currently if that is the case
the new landowner would have to remove
the current signage that exists which
means getting up pulling nails out of
trees that now have been damaged that
now they own might have wanted to sell
for lumber but those but logs have been
damaged by those nails that's labor
intensive whereas covering up the purple
stripe with brown paint is a much easier
cheaper faster way to remove those
no trespassing markings
than pulling down those signs and also
in either case that can be made a
condition of sale they can ask that the
current owner
remove those signs by paint
painting over them before they take over
ownership
so
the personally identifiable information
and i i want to uh point out
something that the lawyer did that i
actually didn't request but i know why
he did it
um in the in paragraph one it has
changed the writing of the name and
address of the owner or lisi
um is optional
now the reason that i know he how he did
this is because we've had a number of
court cases where people who have
trespassed on land
argued that the signage did not include
information of the landowner and
therefore was invalid and they had a
right to be on that land and in every
case the judge has ruled it is the
intent of the landowner that matters not
whether or not they obeyed the actual
letter of the law so in court law
it's basically
deactivated the section
that requires the personal identifiable
information certainly we can all imagine
most of us i would say probably don't
want to put our personal contact
information billboard style out
out in the open so that anybody could
see it
so many landowners don't in fact i was
just walking property uh with someone
who i know is one of the best outdoors
people
that i've ever met and we used the
property note the posted yellow signs to
find the boundary of the property that
we were on and those posted yellow signs
did not contain personal identifiable
information or contact information of
the landowner
now
another issue is well what if what if
somebody's out there and needs to
contact the landowner what if there's an
emergency or what if the the police need
to contact the landowner in every single
one of those k well i would say almost
every single one of those cases the
easier way to find out that contact
information is to look online on the tax
map certainly for municipal police who
are probably very familiar with their
town's website
the tax maps are
updated relatively soon after a sale
whereas signs can stay up for a couple
of years after a sale and certainly the
new landowner may not
switch out those signs just because that
that information is no longer their
contact information they'll say yeah
it's posted that's all i care about so
if you're out in the wilderness and i
remember walking with my friend uh it
took us a few minutes to find those
signs to go the hundred yards look
through the woods and find those yellow
signs so it might take you several
minutes especially if you're in the dark
to go find a sign hope that there is
personal contact information on that
sign whereas you can simply go straight
to the website and find out who owns
that particular piece of land
also there has been
an argument about uh well what is to
prevent
some
rabid anti-hunting activists from going
around just painting trees
to which i say if there's a rabid
anti-hunting activist or any kind of
activist who wants land posted for
whatever reason
they would already be posting signs up
that certainly if you're a rabid and
anti-hunting activist
a couple nails is not going to deter you
from putting up signs
when that's what you want to do i will
point out that it's illegal whether it's
signage or pain it's it's illegal and i
will point to line 16
line 15 and 16 any person found removing
defacing yada yada the property of
another it's not just prohibited it's
actually a criminal penalty class b
misdemeanor but having said that they
would already be doing that do you know
and this is rhetorical how many cases we
have of people actually like actual
recorded cases
of people posting signs on land that
isn't theirs
there's no there's no recorded case
um
however we do have cases of people
tampering with landowner signs
um to try to cover up the fact that they
were on that property when they weren't
supposed to be
and i guess that brings me to
the main point which is in case law
as well as i think just our reasonable
understanding of what property owners
rights should be
we don't the situation we do not want is
people trespassing onto land that they
know that they are not welcome
land that has been bought and purchased
many times because people want privacy
by people who don't want people on their
land
and we don't want people trespassing on
that because of a technicality because
oh this this sign didn't have the
correct information or this sign was not
far enough away or it fell down in a
storm or a squirrel aided or what have
you what that's the situation we don't
want that actually leads to conflict
which is why we've had court cases on
this matter and why the judges have
repeatedly ruled that it's the intent
the clear intent of the landowner that
matters
so with that i'm happy to answer
questions
i have a quick question the the cases
you cited have those gone to the new
hampshire supreme court or those circuit
court cases
i don't believe any of them have gone to
the supreme court have been appealed to
the supreme court okay
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your question or your um testimony
i guess i'm
concerned about
some rabbit as you call them um anti uh
four wheeler uh because my father-in-law
owns a camp or a house in colebrook
and there's a lot of them up there that
want to stop all the four-wheelers noise
in snowmobile noise
but luckily they haven't won yet
hopefully they won't but what would stop
them from just going over painting all
the trails
the purple i know it's against the law
but you know people break the laws every
day right and that's why i mean it's why
we have laws right to prohibit not
prohibit but discourage certain
activities and and we do have a criminal
penalty for this so yes this is already
illegal but my point still stands
whether it's hunting whether it's atvs
but have you that if it's somebody who's
rabidly
you know supporting a
certain position
if they're willing to break the law then
they're certainly willing to go and put
a nail up so if you're not seeing those
people putting those signs up then
there's no effective difference between
them doing that and painting
a follow-up
thank you well
i somewhat disagree because i
currently if you put a posted sign up it
has the landowner's name and number on
it
a spray paint
would be a lot easier
and
how you know then people would be oh
that's trespass you know i can't
trespass on that property where if the
posted signs just up there with no name
you know people are going to question
that
thank you again for the clarification
but as i said uh representative
that this has already gone to court and
the courts have repeatedly ruled that
actually they don't need a personal
contact information on that sign if if
the intent of the landowner is clear if
that sign says no trespassing then
people are to abide by that
and one last follow-up
yep thank you
would you be objected if we change the
fine
from a class b misdemeanor because i i
just see in my eyes of this being an
issue of people spray painting purple
everywhere so that that wish not to see
these four wheelers and snowmobiles uh
to like a felony charge
um i personally for the purposes of this
bill don't necessarily have a problem
with it i would like to point out that
um
lines 15 and 16 already exist in our
current law this is not something i've
added in this bill the only thing that's
been added is the word paint marks to be
inclusive of this new alternative method
of posting
so um this is something that
we've already settled is what we
consider to be a class b misdemeanor but
if this committee decided that um
defacing somebody's property or posting
on somebody's land that it wasn't their
right to post on is something that is
felony level or maybe you might want to
go to class a first
before you get to a felony um
that's certainly
that doesn't touch the intent of my bill
so i'm as far as this bill is concerned
without weighing in on like what should
and shouldn't be a felony that it i
would be fine with that but again that
would be up the purview of this
committee thank you
representative green
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question how would this bill
distinguish between a landowner that
would allow people to walk his land
or possibly allow people to use a
snowmobile or an atv but not allow
hunting
thank you for that question it's a good
question and the thing is this does not
remove the current method the current
method specifically states and it gives
an example of no hunting or trespassing
states that you can prohibit certain
activities without prohibiting all
trespassers so if you want to be
granular and say i would like i'm fine
with certain activities on my land but i
don't want these other activities you
can still use the current method and put
those signs up saying no atvs or atv's
okay no hunting or hunting okay no
whatever
you can still you can already do that
and you would still be able to do that
with this what this does is just allow a
very easy safe quick way
for people especially people who
currently find it very difficult to go
around the perimeter of their likely
wooded and rocky land
who may find it physically difficult
to put a more durable way to post
everything up which is not to say that
they won't allow people on their land
just as you all know currently you can
post no trespassing and then give
particular people the right to be on
your land to hunt you can invite your
friends over to a party just because you
have no trespassing doesn't mean people
can't come it means they need your
verbal permission so all of that can
still happen this just provides an
alternative for people to express their
already existent property owner rights
there being no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you so much
the committee now calls linda dion
morning
committee members thank you for allowing
me to speak i don't have
a whole lot but i was just going to say
i'm a i'm a landowner i don't have a
whole lot of land but i have woods
behind me
and there's trails out there there's a
wetland
and i but i don't post and part of the
reason i don't post is because i don't
want to put my name and address
out there for everyone to see
so it's a privacy reason i also don't
like the idea of putting signs in the
woods
that uh pollute and i'm a little bit of
an environmentalist also
and these signs you probably think that
paper but they're not they're made of a
synthetic material and the second page
of my
testimony
talks about what what the signs are made
of they are plastic
they will be there for a long long time
they do not decompose and um
animals everyone knows that animals are
like small children they see something
in the woods and they like to put it in
their mouth and um
so it's
i don't know if you just saw that turtle
that swallowed the ribbon on the news
and had to have surgery uh that's what
animals do they see something and they
like to ingest it
um
so it's dangerous these signs are
dangerous for the the wildlife out there
and um
i guess that's about it that's the
reason i don't post i would put
paint on my trees but
these signs are not good for the
environment
and that's all i have
thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls christina snyder
uh good afternoon
thank you for having me i um
i'm actually uh in support of this bill
uh very strongly
the thing is property owners landowners
we have the right to post our property
we have the right to post against
trespass
however like the onus of hardship is
incredible for the landowner what we
have to do on our property
every year is we have to go around the
perimeter we have to check for these
signs
yes they get ripped off they get ripped
down the animals do chew on them it it
every year we have to pay for the signs
we actually because they get ripped down
so easily we lug a ladder through the
woods
climb up this ladder and put nails into
our trees
and nails are not good for trees so now
we have the choice do we harm our trees
just to exercise our right to post our
property it shouldn't be that difficult
i want to emphasize that new hampshire
fish and game strongly strongly suggests
that hunters contact the land owner
before they hunt no it's not required
but they strongly urge that because
there has been increasing issues
with hunters
littering putting up illegal tree stands
and and issues like that and and with
this purple paint it just makes it
easier now if i didn't have a partner
you know i'm five foot one
i weigh 106 pounds am i supposed to lug
a ladder through the woods to exercise
my rights to post my property why why is
it that difficult it shouldn't be that
difficult and here's the thing even if
your land is painted with these purple
stripes
since fish and games says please contact
the landowner
they it's it's fine that some of these
people that might have it posted might
have a friend or a cousin or brother or
an uncle and say it's okay if you you
hunt on my land thank you for asking
thank you to for coming to me and thank
you for giving me some of your harvest
and then that way they have written
permission and that person can still
hunt on that property it just makes it
so that not every random hunter or every
random person comes through it gives the
land owner
discretion with their property and what
they do with it it shouldn't be that
difficult when we have to go through and
we have to we see these signs ripped off
or shot at
it
it's just becoming completely a hardship
on the land owner and as as far as as as
with the colorblind you know i sent in
testimony and i sent in some quotes from
several sources there's a little bit of
confusion on that because some some say
that purple is actually one of the
colors that's easier for colorblind
people to see i don't know however there
is also that eight percent
of uh males are colorblind so now if you
have
say very generous a hundred thousand
hunters eight percent so you have eight
thousand hunters and that's generous and
they're colorblind so now
the hundreds of thousands of people that
own property
you know
our our rights are not easy we can't
exercise those rights because we have to
worry about a few thousand hunters that
can't
ask their buddy and say hey i'm scouting
out this property i see this paint on
this tree hey can you tell me what color
that is it's that simple
it you know when i see all of these
discussions against this it's it's
it's just frustrating as as property
owners because i also know several
people
some elderly people you know my parents
they wanted to post their property no
way is is my 80 year old father gonna
get up on a ladder
you know so i have to go and help him
and do that it just it just shouldn't be
that difficult this isn't going to stop
hunting it's just going to to make it
easier for the landowner and
you know that's that's pretty much all i
have to say so i will take any questions
representative muse
thanks for taking my question
when you say
getting up on the ladder you you get up
on a ladder to post a sign
because you're trying to put the sign
out of reach of somebody who could
easily tear it down is that the
rationale
yes previous we would just go uh with my
partner and he would reach up as far as
he could
uh and then he he'd tack in into the
tree with the nails destroying the tree
which we we took the chance and we did
and what we found was yeah they were
easier because anybody could just go
through and just it's easier for them to
just be pulled down and we did find that
when we lug the ladder through the woods
and put the signs up higher
it's it's a little more difficult for
them to get ripped down and and
destroyed that way
thank you
thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls
patrick hackley new hampshire division
of forests and lands
and just before the witness begins just
to the members of the committee if you
look in your draws in the committee
office there's an updated
book for all of us who i strongly
recommend you bring with you you can
leave it in your drawer
and once you have one
all set
all right
good afternoon chairman abbas and
members of the committee
for the record my name is patrick
hackley i'm the director for the
division of forest and lands and also
called the state forester
i just want to thank you for the
opportunity to testify on hb 1108
the department of natural and cultural
resources division of forests and lands
does not take a position on this bill
but i'd like to offer the following
comments
the division of forest and lands is the
state agency charged with the execution
of all matters pertaining to forestry
forest management
and forest lands within the jurisdiction
of the state
one of the division's key
responsibilities is to enforce the state
timber harvesting laws including cases
of timber trespass
where
boundaries are very critical part of
that enforcement and also to main uh
manage forest fire protection programs
and activities in cooperation with local
municipalities
uh the division of forest lands uh we
manage about 170 000 acres of state land
we also manage about 60 000 acres of
land for the new hampshire fish and game
department and 13 000 acres of land for
the
army corps of engineers in the flood
control areas of the state
i've also been a forester for about 35
years
so this bill as proposed raises several
concerns for us
purple boundary paint to indicate no
trespassing is a completely uncommon
practice in the northeast and is not
widely recognized by the majority of
landowners foresters surveyors and
forest recreationists
posted signs are well recognized and can
be easily added or removed
as the landowner desires or ownerships
change as opposed to essentially
permanent paint marking
and i've listened intently to the the
previous speakers and i understand the
frustration and concern but
um consulting with a forester to advise
them on how to how to attach these signs
to a tree
would be worth their while
you can use a half inch or quarter
quarter inch galvanized nail
and and just tap that into the tree
you don't even have to tap it in
completely to hold a very light vinyl
sign
so the nailing does not destroy the tree
necessarily and
can still be considered a valuable
timber product
as far as posting goes the landowner's
name and address on posted signs we
believe that should remain a requirement
of this law
having landowners contact information
facilitates communication
so i don't see why
we would want to remove the ability for
forest visitors to be able to understand
whose land they're on
you it's just another form of
communication and i also realize it's
not well
uh
followed by the by many landowners they
might put their name but don't want to
put their address and the other speakers
are correct you a lot of times you can
find it in the tax rolls but that's only
if those tax rolls and that tax
information is online some towns do not
have all that information online
so
having landowners contact information
it allows
hunters who need to contact the
landowner in order to retrieve wounded
or killed game
temporary access across posted property
is also often needed for forestry
operations and again this is another
form of communication that
a logger can use to contact the lane
owner to see if they can cross their
land for operations and then of course
our our agency is responsible for forest
fire suppression
and uh
again learning that the name and address
of the landowner allows us to facilitate
access for fire suppression activities
so
the pain in the current posting law we
feel is a well-established time tested
standard
for boundary marking used by licensed
surveyors foresters that are far more
effective than than the
provisions proposed in this bill
with that i'll conclude my comments
representative
conley thank you and thank you for
taking the question i live in a
small city but a city nonetheless so
this is an issue i've given much thought
to but
seems like the property owners are
being forced to do a lot of things
to meet the letter of the law here and
i'm i'm curious why we wouldn't let them
choose
a method
one or more method or an alternative
method to post their property
versus what's in statute i'm wondering
what the harm is there
the biggest concern thank you for the
question representative the biggest
concern is the confusion that it would
cause i mean there are going to be very
few visitors to the forest that are
going to understand what purple paint is
signs are typically the standard
uh posted signs if you really want to
send a message that your land is posted
that's what this law does it provides
the sideboards for that purple paint is
just
i've as i mentioned i've been a forester
for three three and a half decades
i've walked forests from northern maine
to western new york
and everywhere in between in between
purple's just not the color i mean it
might be in other states
but it's just not going to be well
recognized and cause confusion
representative calling thank you
shouldn't it be on the onus of whomever
intends to cross onto private property
to make sure
whatever the rule is whatever the law is
that
they are following the law before they
traipse onto another person's property
and wouldn't this ensure that
purple orange
signs
i guess the questions could they still
achieve that
and shouldn't they still achieve that
regardless of how it's marked
so we have an open door policy in new
england as you may know where if the
land is not posted
then it's assumed that that individual
can walk onto the land
so there's
that's basically how it how it exists
here in new england
so signage is the one way to communicate
that
if you own land of any significance
beyond a house lot
it's it behooves landowner to paint
their boundaries and make them very
visible they do that with a blaze a
blaze is an ax mark that
takes it down to the to the bare wood
and then it's painted with an
all-purpose weatherproof paint that
lasts between 10 and 15 years
so the onus is on the landowner to
define their boundaries to ensure that
no one trespasses
or at least they they know they're
crossing a change in ownership
but the color of the paint is typically
as traditionally not
does not communicate that that that is
posted it just mentions it just
indicates you're crossing a boundary
line
representative roy
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
does the current statute require nails
or would zip ties work
i don't think it requires how it should
be attached to the tree
my understanding
representative muse
yes thank you for taking my question one
of the things i'm a little confused
about is is is your standing here so in
your testimony uh you said the division
of forests and lands manages 170 000
acres of of state land
but what we're talking about here are
private landowners
uh not not the state
so
does your
agency actually have just jurisdiction
over private landowners
thank you for the question
representative um
part of our declaration of purpose as an
agency i'm sorry i can't see you with
the speaker in the way
um is that
we we promote
a thriving forest products industry and
good forestry so we provide education
outreach to landowners as part of our
mission
and so the interests of private forest
land owners is baked into our mission so
that's why i'm here today is to kind of
represent
landowners who are trying to manage
their land um that and we support and
uh support
you know their their efforts which
includes maintaining boundaries
representative muse you recognize for a
follow-up
would you say
in terms of your relationship to private
landowners you consider yourself to be
more of a resource for them
absolutely education information unh
cooperative extension
is a strategic partner in that in that
effort and they provide training they
want to say training but they provide
outreach workshops to private land
owners and funding comes from the u.s
foreign service through us to extension
to educate landowners
thank you you're welcome
thanks for the question
representative burt thank you mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony today
you've touched
a little bit on it somebody sent me a
message about
if if you could explain
what common land rule is in new
hampshire compared to some of the other
states i believe that have this law that
do not have common land rule if you
could explain what that means
yeah i don't know the definition of
common land rule what in the context of
the previous speaker mentioned
commonland rule
mr chairman follow-up
recognized for follow-up thank you uh no
uh no they didn't mention competition
new hampshire is common land rule and
you touched base on it that
in new hampshire if the land's not
posted i can walk on it until asked to
leave yes where some of the other states
are not that that use this striping as a
color sure yeah yeah if you could just
explain what you know the difference
between some states in new hampshire is
that i'm allowed to do certain things
where i'm not in other states sure all
right thank you for the question um
i don't have the knowledge in terms of
what other states do i was the first
time i'd heard that pennsylvania does
that that actually they have they allow
the landowner to paint it in purple
um but i can tell you that that is
unusual in the northeast as far as the
common land um
you know
private land ownership is obviously a
cherished right of
of everyone in america
um
in new england we do have a it's it's
actually a wonderful tradition that
people will leave their land
unposted to allow for for
responsible public use
and so
i i don't know if it's the same term
common land versus
um
open door policy if you will or open
gate policy but
that is essentially what um it's been
called for many decades in new england
now that tradition is eroding as we all
know more and more people are posting
their land for various reasons that's
their right
but in new england by and large we still
have a tremendous amount of open land
people that
allow the public to recreate on it our
statewide trail system as you may have
is dependent
on private landowners being willing
to allow trails across their property
so it's it's a wonderful
tradition and we're trying to protect
that by promoting responsible private
use of public oh i'm sorry private
responsible private use of of private
lands
thank you
sure
representative pratt
i just have one question uh you
mentioned earlier machete slashing and
painting
that's just acceptable practice
well machete would be probably not the
most useful tool but a blaze yeah we
call it a blaze in forestry lingo so who
does that
surveyors do it all the time uh
foresters can also do it but it's
consist considered a physical monument
that's once that's that blaze is made
it has to be made by a licensed surveyor
to become a monument
that can be painted like i said
depending on the the conditions of the
forest if it's high elevation you
probably have to paint at least every 10
years
if it's in a in a place where the
weather conditions are not as harsh
you know every 15 years might be good
there's one follow-up
you recognize for a follow-up
so you have borderline trees it's okay
for a severe to come through and slash
your tree and paint it
good question thank you um
so
when you paint the trees
you really
have to have physical monuments usually
there's a previous blaze mark that
you're working off of if a landowner is
not sure if they don't have a
licensed survey completed on their
property
they would be well advised to work with
their adjacent lane owner to walk that
line together
okay yeah thank you all right
thank you for your testimony thank you
the committee now calls
roy schweitzweiker
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee i'm roy schweiker from concord
and i'd ask your indulgence i only asked
for a couple of minutes to speak but i
think i can answer some of the questions
that have been given and respond to some
of the things have been said so i'd like
a little longer anyway
this has nothing to do with new
hampshire
but it has something to do with marking
land
for five years i've been a volunteer for
the national park service
maintaining the boundaries of the
appalachian trail which goes through the
woods and we
have a boundary it's a very long
boundary
and there are volunteers that go out and
maintain it we use a special yellow
paint that has some special chemical in
it that only the federal government can
use so nobody else can sneak up and put
the
official yellow blazes that we use
and the way it works is a licensed
surveyor went through they set metal
monuments
and they blaze trees
and trees that are on the line with the
blaze facing along the line and trees
are when a certain distance of the line
is ablated on the side of the tree
all these yellow
and
that's how the property is marked
and the problem we have is there are
places where there aren't trees
and therefore you can't put glazes on
them
so it's kind of hard to follow the line
through there if it's bushes
i go out and i put up surveyors tape
because that's not a legal boundary
marker so i can do it
but of course that doesn't last as long
and our experience
with the
appalachian trail is more like five
years that the blazes start to fade
and remember that these blades are
bright yellow
so they're designed to be visible
and so therefore if the bright yellow
paint with a special chemical is fading
in five years
i think the landowners are going to
discover that
they're maybe not quite so good paint
maybe fade quicker than that
and the other thing about it is we also
have property signs we put up
and
those are plastic signs
and they do degrade over time
they
come loose and whatnot we have to pick
them off and take them away and put up
new ones
and we do not use galvanized nails
we use aluminum nails
so if somehow that nail is left in the
tree it's less likely to affect the
sauce somebody happens to saw into it
but the chief thing i want to say about
this painting and
putting up signs is putting up signs is
far easier
to go out and paint a section of that
you can't even do a mile and a day
probably
you know just going finding every tree
putting paint on it
whereas the signs you can walk right
along
she was talking about 100 yards
we
do them
usually every 200 feet because the
monuments are 400 feet apart and we put
one halfway in between
we can put up those markers a whole lot
quicker
than we could paint the thing so
painting is not easier it's harder
to the extent that the
signs can stay up and don't have to be
replaced every year
and
if i say we use the aluminum nails
so theoretically they won't damage the
saw blades if the tree gets logged
and
i don't know i suppose you could use a
tie except a lot of the trees are too
big around you need an awfully long tie
and depending on the species if it
doesn't have the rough bar maybe you use
staples which once again probably
wouldn't damage the saw and wouldn't go
in very far into the wood so
i don't see that
the sign the signs are easier to put up
but you may have to put up more often
and they don't damage the tree if you do
it properly
and
the paint may not last as long as people
are talking about if you want to be
visible you want the stuff to be close
together
so anyway that's my experience from
vermont on marking boundaries
the other thing i wanted to say has to
do with this
common land or whatever that you know
that's
left over from the native americans
originally you know they didn't own land
they just traveled through it used it as
they needed it and it's in the british
common law that seems to have come into
new england
and
i like it
an example in vermont if you think
handlings have a tough in new hampshire
in vermont you not only have to put your
name on the sign you've got to date it
every year
you've got to go to the town office and
record it and pay what's a nominal fee
but it's a lot more trouble
because
in vermont apparently they have this
attitude that you know land should be
open
and they're willing to make it a little
bit more difficult for the landowner if
they want to post it for some reason
and as far as the signs themselves
you know my big gripe about them is you
go to the hardware store you can buy a
sign that says no trespassing for any
purpose
really cheap
and people tend to put those up
instead of trying to indicate the
particular things that they want you to
stay away from
but you know that's merely a gripe
there's a lot of people now have found
some way to get a sign that says no
hunting with bear dogs
because they're particularly opposed to
that i'm sure that cost them far more
than just buying a generic sign
and as far as contacting people
this place in vermont they put up a sign
no hunting without permission that's
great
that's not a legal sign in vermont but
you know
like people have said you know don't you
want to do what the landowner wants
so i decided i would contact these
people well guess what
they didn't have the name on the sign
because it wasn't a legal sign anyway
so i have to go first to the topographic
maps to try and figure out where this is
that particular town had the
tax maps online so i was able to find
out the
partial number and i was able to contact
the town office in vermont it is a
public record the owner of a parcel
so they were able to give me the name
and address of the person who owned that
parcel and then i was able to contact
him and say can i go hiking on your
piece of prop and i said sure
but you know i was a very convoluted
system
and this is why it would be nice
you know once again if people want their
property to be used for the purpose they
want and if they want people to contact
themselves sneaking on you know saying
that signs illegal so i'm going to
ignore it would really help if they
would be
you know
cognizant of the fact that some people
might be interested in
you know doing the right thing
i'm not going to go hunt on your land
with bear dogs you have a sign that says
that
but
how can i
and i'm not going to tell you you've got
things to do i'm going to tell you more
stories about dealings i've had with
landowners but anyway that's my feeling
i think that the paint
like the previous gentleman said is not
going to be recognized so it's not going
to have the effect it's going to be far
more trouble to deal with than you think
the guy who buys that land and doesn't
want to post it
that's another thing i've had experience
with it takes twice as much to cover up
the paint as it did to paint it
originally he's not going to do it so
that land is going to be you know out of
the system for ever just because one
person put up some purple paint
so anyway that's why i'm opposed to this
bill thank you
thank you for your
testimony the committee now calls jason
stock new hampshire timberland so owners
association
well good afternoon
by one minute
my name is jason stock the executive
director of the new hampshire timberland
owners association
we represent timberland owners in the
state's forest products industry
our members own and or manage about a
million acres across the state of new
hampshire
and our our membership ranges from large
what i would say commercial owners
folks like weyerhaeuser investment funds
real estate investment trust
to
tree farms 10 acres
and so and everything in between
and
most of i would say most of our members
lands are open are open for
what we call passive recreation
pedestrian recreation
and as you heard earlier today that's
kind of a new england tradition
but there are people that do post and
they post for a variety of reasons
either they create safety zones around
livestock their buildings their homes
things of that nature
and
but i've come here today to speak in
opposition to this bill
and
for a couple reasons
and i'm not going to belabor it but
you've heard some of it already
there's a question
there's a question about
there's a question about recognition
one of our members has land in the state
of maine which allows purple paint and
when i asked him about it he said you
know
what's maine's experience he said his
words to me was it's kind of a joke over
there
people don't really know what it means
it's not it's not part of the
traditional land use and he says it
almost create for that landowner it
creates more more of an issue
than solves
people understand they recognize signage
the signage can get very explicit in
terms of
no bear dogs no posting for any reason
etc so it's
you know the the posting itself
we believe that the current process
works
um
and as you heard from the state forester
there are reasons why you want to have a
landowner's name and at least contact
information up there
um and
you know
opportunities or reasons where they were
they you want to facilitate that
communication
a game animal travels over onto your
property and it's posted
give me you know i'd like a heads up
okay you're going to retrieve that deer
great
the other piece is
why you would want is you as you heard
earlier fire suppression contact them
something's going on out there
mr mrs landowner we need to contact you
many of our members lands are in remote
areas so access to tax maps and in wi-fi
hotspots or internet access it's not
really an option if you're on the back
side of
smarts mountain up in the canaan area
you know wi-fi access is just not an
option up there but if you have a name
up there
and you have a an address it's a heck of
a lot easier to kind of locate who the
person is and kind of track them down if
you need to talk to them about
accessing their property
and again as you heard earlier
paint
the paint the property sold the paint
remains and now the new landowner has to
deal with it granted it could be a
condition of sale but it's just another
it's just another variable in the mix
so i guess i i'll i'll conclude my
testimony there you've heard it you've
heard all the the reasons
why this bill we don't feel it's
necessary is one of my my policy
committee members said this is a
solution
looking for a problem right now we have
a posting process we have a tradition of
open space and land use it's working
we really don't this the feeling is this
bill is just not necessary
with that i'll conclude my testimony be
happy to try and answer any questions
representative roy thank you mr chairman
thank you for taking my question
i wonder if there if there isn't some
room for compromise
what if the statute were changed so that
you extended the distance between the
necessary uh posting of the name
and were allowed to purple paint say for
200 yards or 300 yards and then you had
a sign with the name so that someone
could
take the time and walk a little bit
further and find the person's name yet
save the homeowner the burden of having
to put signs every so often as it is now
how how would you see that
i i guess
the way i i mean i certainly open to
consider i guess my point though in
coming here today was that the current
process
works um
again it's been established
over many many many years people know
what what the requirements are
and if it if it ain't broke why try to
fix it it's kind of our
our approach to this
thank you
representative muse
yes one of the things i'm curious about
is we've heard a lot of talk today about
what's required of people who want to
post their land and the idea that people
you know that contact information is a
good thing to have and it's necessary
and it helps people out
i i think i can understand what i'm
curious about though is it sounds like
the vast majority in private private
land in new hampshire is not posted
so in a situation where land is not
posted
how do you get in touch with somebody if
you have you know a fire protection
issue or one of these other issues
where you find it helpful to have
information about the landowner
sure
great question and thank you for thank
you for asking i think what we're what
we're talking about here is is slightly
slightly different in the sense that
when you post a piece of property
you can't access that property
you can't access that property without
permission if the property is not posted
and
and you need to access that property
you can particularly if it's a situation
where you need to access it and there's
a time time factor there you've got a
game animal you've got a fire situation
um and in that instance
there's no question you can access it if
it's not posted
what we're talking about here is if this
darn speaker if it is posted
all right before i
can do what i need to do follow the
animal or deal with the fire situation i
the posting adds a step
so the point is
if you're not posted you don't have that
that step in there once you post it
now you have this landowner notification
step and for that reason having the name
and address is important
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
coming
and testifying today
to go back to
you know the posted signs it's it's
obvious that it's
a wooden well most people put them on
plywood and then nail them up
but
would it be easier
for somebody that wants to break the law
and to say hey i'm going to post all
this property even though i don't own it
with a wooden sign or with just a spray
paint
obviously i think splashing paint is
easier than going through the effort of
creating a wooden sign and putting it up
on be it a tree or pole so my answer
would be i think my opinion
the paint would be easier to to apply
than
posting a sign as you had said on a
piece of plywood onto a tree
most of the postings that i see
typically don't use plywood
but even so um
you know the the paint would be i think
the paint would be easier but you heard
testimony i haven't done i haven't done
either i own land it's open to
recreation i encourage people to use it
so i i can't tell you from personal
experience
thank you
representative true
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um is uh
are nails and trees a problem
for the companies that are harvesting
trees
nails yes nails are nails are problems
in trees you talk to any lumbermen
and well you go into any lumberman's
office and they usually have a little
bookshelf with all the little
things they find in in trees when they
when they open them up and saw them
um but as you heard earlier there are
ways around that using
aluminum nails which are softer than
steel saw blades are made of steel there
are other types of nails
in staple types of staples that can be
used but
metal nails you know steel particularly
steel in trees if you're going to cut it
for lumber that's a problem
thank you for your testimony thank you
the committee calls major walsh new
hampshire fish and game
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee
my name is dave walsh i'm the assistant
chief of law enforcement for the new
york fish and game department
first i would contend that probably
nobody deals with posted land and posted
land issues more than a conservation
officer with fish and game the other
thing i think that i hope you would all
agree is outdoor recreation is a huge
part of new hampshire's economy and it's
a huge part of new hampshire's way of
life
the first thing i did when this bill
came out is i called the state of maine
they implemented the purple paint law in
2011 and i called the maine wooden
service and asked how is the purple
paint log going and they laughed and
they said utter chaos
they find more hunters and hikers on
purple painted land
because they have no idea what it means
and that's been in place now for 10
years for a decade
a lot of the points that i'll make i'll
keep short because they've been brought
up again but if a landowner
sells land which happens a lot in the
state
and let's say it's 200 acres and it's
painted purple and the new owner comes
in and they want to keep that land open
to outdoor recreation that's a lot of
work to either scrape the bark or go
around with brown paint and cover it up
and to someone's point earlier
many of those landowners might not do
that effort so they don't want to post
their land but now we have unintended
posted land because they don't want to
go through that effort an unintended
posted land is not what we need in the
state of new hampshire
the other thing is if a landowner
changes their mind let's say they post
their land with purple paint
and then they decide they want to have
some current use some land in current
use and change the allowable uses on the
land outdoor recreation now they got to
go through that f again or many
landowners will allow certain things
they might allow hiking but not hunting
so
now they're going to have to go through
this the purple and if they've already
had purple paint in their land leave
they have to cover up that purple paint
or put a sign on it or next to it and
now if you have purple paint next to a
sign
what came first and it's just confusion
to people
as as a previous speaker said the system
works the way it is and it's it's uh
it's nothing that we we could own
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
representative conley thank you
and thank you for taking the question
we've heard from landowners who say the
system is not working
um and we have two in the room and i
suspect there's many more across the
state who would
would love to not have to deface their
trees and their property and walk the
perimeter and so forth so
um
i guess i'd ask you the same question
is there harm in giving them a choice
in the means that they would they would
mark their property
which would be their right as a property
owner sure so i've been doing this for
24 years and i can tell you the vast
majority of people that do post alien to
use tyvek paper with staple gun or
aluminum nails so the tree issue isn't
an issue
from what i've seen in my career
i i agree with representative roy that
there could be some room to add some
signage with purple paint but if it's
just paint
all i see is confusion and
i don't see it working
thank you for your testimony thank you
the committee calls joan o'brien
thank you chair members of the committee
so i've just been listening here and i
actually did quite a bit of research
into this because i'm one of these
people that had difficulty posting my
land i'm not quite as
short and skinny as this woman before me
but close
and it did take a ladder
and i did have to go around the year
later and i saw that all my tyvek signs
had folded in so i
invested in better plastic signs which
cost me a lot and went back and did all
my labor again
but what i wanted to say mostly is that
this is about landowner rights and
the practice is spreading throughout the
country and i think for the same reasons
we want it here the rest of the country
is finding that they need it as well and
we've got more than half the states now
with either laws or legislation that
they're considering
and that includes in in the northeast
we've got maine which was mentioned
pennsylvania and both
new york and vermont currently have
legislation that they're considering to
add the purple paint law as well
um
whenever there's a change there's some
public public education that needs to
happen
and um in searching i saw that the
local news and the newspapers would
cover you know if if the law passed they
would they'd have a little spot on the
news that said you can now you know post
your property with purple paint in
pennsylvania or whatever it was and the
newspapers cover it and i think new
hampshire fish and game is extremely
good at public education and they could
spread the word that way as well
the paint itself
you can buy it from rust-oleum you can
buy it from krylon there's another
company called magic that makes it so
it's widely available in lowe's home
depot it's it's a thing and and people
will get used to it and they'll see it
they'll start to learn what it means and
they'll see they'll read things when
they hear from fish and game what it
means and they'll get with the program
and i think that's
all i have to say
thank you very much
representative newman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um i'm a representative from nashua and
there's not a lot of hunting in nashua
so maybe you can educate me just a
little bit
could you speak to
i don't know about hunting licenses and
whether residents or non-residents need
them um but could you educate me or give
me your opinion about
if when a license is
gotten when somebody gets a license
if in fact they do
could this type of education be
handed out when the license is is given
to the person explaining what purple
is i would imagine um i mean you need to
know a lot if you're going to be a
hunter you need to know all the dates
all the seasons all the bag limits so
it's just another thing that you need to
learn about
thank you
thank you for your testimony
this time we'll now close the public
hearing on house bill 1108
and the committee will be
in recess to 1 10 p.m
um
good afternoon
at this time we will now open the public
hearing on house bill
1433 relative to the penalties for
poisoning dogs
this time the chair recognizes
representative sullivan to introduce the
bill
thank you mr chairman and
um representative brian sullivan i
represent sullivan district one
consisting of the towns of grantham
springfield plainfield and cornish
and it's uh
my pleasure to be here to introduce
house bill 1433
uh you may remember me from last year
when i came
to
introduce house bill 3 um 338
that bill was
a related topic it dealt with
dog collars
and
it's sort of relevant to this bill as
well because i wouldn't be here if it
weren't for that bill
basically house bill 338 last year
was heard by this committee amended by
this committee and passed by this
committee
and of course went on to the other body
when it arrived there they also had a
hearing in the uh
the
energy and natural resources committee
during that hearing um
there was
a concern raised
by the co-chairs of the governor's
commission on humane treatment of
animals
the bill that
was was in place
addressed
tampering with dog collars
and removing microchips the concern
really didn't deal with
either of those issues it dealt with
dog
the poisoning of dogs
so once the hearing was over i got a
call from the
assistant to the chair
and
was asked if i could get together with
those co-chairs to discuss their concern
we did that we had a conference call and
we came to an agreement
they would either i'm not sure if it was
they agreed to support or at least not
oppose
house bill of 338
and i agreed to address their concern
this year
so here i am
uh
house bill 1433
um
seeks to do three things
first
it seeks to place poison of animals
including dogs in rsa 644 the criminal
code under cruelty to animals
it also seeks to repeal the section of
rsa 466
colon 42-a
that deals with the poisoning of dogs
it further repeals rsa
644 colon 16 to allow poisoning of
animals to be moved
to section 8 of rsa 644
it is primarily a housekeeping bill
um
and essentially puts the poisoning of
dogs
in with the poisoning of animals in the
proper statute
under criminal justice or criminal code
um jerely zazullo co-chair of the
governor's commission on the humane
treatment of animals
is also here to testify she was the
motivator behind
this bill
and can go into
more detail as to why they sought to
have this take place but it was
my pleasure to
bring this bill on their behalf
and they're a joy to work with with that
i'll take any questions you might have
representative newman you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
and it has to do with the uh on page two
lines four the the removal uh it lists
what's uh
repealed
and my confusion is what when stuff is
bolded and not bolded and when it's in
the real with the current law or is it a
new new stuff that is just not bolded
for some reason
and if someone else you think might have
better knowledge to talk about that i'd
be happy to wait until someone else is
there
the bill as printed is a little bit uh
a little bit difficult to decipher
on the first page um you will see the
the bold uh printed material um and that
is indeed the new uh section on on
poisoning of animals not necessarily
just dogs but poisoning of animals um
then on the
at the very end on page two um it very
briefly um indicates that it would
repeal rsa 64416
relating to the exposing poisons to
animals nrsa 466
42 dash a
roman 2 relative to the poisoning of
dogs
so it um
essentially
repeals those two pieces
and puts the poisoning of animals in the
um
the
current statute here
rsa
644 colon8
thank you
representative conley
thank you if i may piggyback on my
colleague from nashua's comment so uh
one of the things that i think dover
residents are least proud of is we've
had a problem with rats a lot of
development a lot of rats and people are
taking it upon themselves
to place poison out in the neighborhood
and so forth and i'm wondering about
that last
section that you just described
what sort of intent would be required to
be caught up in this if
an animal were to ingest the substance
that was placed
around one's property but
had an effect on an animal other than a
rat
as i understand it if you intentionally
poison um
uh the types of animals covered by this
which would be um
uh domestic animals um or
wildlife in captivity
it would be probably deemed a negligent
act i'm sorry if you intentionally do it
it would be um
a higher uh penalty than if you um
do something by accident um negligence
um i believe is a misdemeanor um the
intentional poisoning of an animal um
would be a felony
representative rory
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um i hire actually an
extermination company i live out in the
woods and we get field mice and they
come and they put these bait traps
around the foundation of my house
now if my neighbor's dog comes over and
chews through one of those needs to
poison would i fall under the negligent
poisoning of an animal in the statute or
no
i'm not law enforcement um so i'm not
sure exactly how that would be treated
but i would say there is potential for
that
thank you
representative splain
thank you mr chair thank you
for taking my question
much like mr roy i live out in the
middle of nowhere and my closest
neighbors a quarter mile plus away
it's not uncommon that i find the
neighbor's dog in my yard especially
since i also have a dog
and
i am frequently putting out poison for
mice around the foundation of my house
and or in my garage
should their dog decide to eat my poison
for the mice even if it's in a
controlled box
why should i be liable for their dog
coming on my property
a quarter mile away when there's leash
laws in the town
i don't see anything in here that that
basically says if you're on your own
property and you're poisoning on your
own property that there's no
negligence here
i think you're right
um that
basically law enforcement would have to
evaluate whether or not that dog being
on your property that far away from
their place not on a leash
might be a mitigating circumstance but
again i'm not law enforcement
you're recognized for follow-up
thank you for the follow-up
if we purposefully put into law
something that makes somebody
liable for that type of behavior
and then we say it's up on law
enforcement to mitigate that
that's an injustice to everyone in this
state
we need to ensure that our laws are
correct before we enact them
i would also point out that uh
poisoning of animals is currently
in the law what this bill intends to do
is to move it from from one part of the
law to another so it's more easily
identified
in the cruelty to animals section
representative bert
thank you mr chairman i do have a
question for the uh representative but
if you wouldn't mind if i have a
question for you first mr chairman
um you recognized for a parliamentary
inquiry all right thank you
if if i'm reading
first page
line 15 to 19
i'm reading it as if i put poison out
uh to protect my building or crops that
i am not going to i'm exempt if a dog
comes onto my property am i reading that
wrong
excuse me i interpreted this and this is
my interpretation which i i'm not
testifying i'll just point that out
it's not really a parliamentary inquiry
might i have
but
it seems to be have an exception if you
put out some type of poison control to
deal with rats or other type of
vermin
so
it allows an exception for that
i i would just tell any member of the
committee while well since i'm answering
a question
and since we all just got our updated
books recently i know that some subs but
if you look at rsa 626 colon 2
roman numeral 2
d
is the definition of
negligently
which may also
help understand the application of this
if it were to become law
so that's a person acts negligibly with
respect to a material element of an
offense when he fails to become aware of
a substantial risk and unjustifiable
risk
that the material element exists or will
result from his conduct risk must be of
such a nature and degree that his
failure to become aware of its
constitutes a gross deviation from the
conduct that a reasonable person would
observe in that situation
so that's just from an application
yes
and if i may ask the you may you may ask
the witness a question okay thank you mr
chairman and thank you uh for clearing
that up
um and thank you for
testing your testimony
i think i'm a little confused too like
you know the first speaker about what is
changes and i'm looking at lines 25 and
26 and then also 27 through 30
is
what is not bolded
is that current law
absolutely yes all right so what is what
follow-ups
you recognize for a follow-up thank you
uh mr chairman and so it's just the
words being added and i was also looking
at line two which is currently if
somebody is found guilty
of and this is current law if i'm
understanding this correctly if somebody
poisons an animal um it's a misdemeanor
first then second offense would go to a
felony charge
is that
that is the current law yes okay that's
thank you so we're not adding anything
the only things that uh have changed in
rsa 644 colon eight 8
is
what is bold
thank you i appreciate you clearing that
up
representative plain
thank you again mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
my further question comes from the
specificity of
uh and persons using poison to control
rats and other vermin in their building
or to protect their crops
i raise chickens
and i frequently put out poison in the
chicken coop or around the chicken coop
to prevent rats and vermin from going
into the chicken coop to either steal
the chicken
feed
or to go after the eggs from the
chickens which they will do
there's nothing here to protecting
livestock protecting
the value of your your reap from your
livestock and or crops it only deals
with crops and buildings representatives
plain is there is there a question
yeah
is there it does this apply
also to
protecting of livestock with poison
i i think i would defer to the next
witness on that
um she's far more familiar with the
humane treatment of animals than i am
thank you representative for your
testimony
the committee now calls terrorily
from the governor's
council on the humane treatment of
animals
i'm sorry i can't read your writing one
if you don't mind just spelling your
name for the records for the clerk
thank you
what's that on now okay my name is
jerely zazula i'm
co-chair of the governor's commission on
the humane treatment of animals
on the commission i represent the
general public
we the governor's commission
um
looks at
any new legislation coming through
to see if and how it affects the welfare
of animals
and every legislative session we go
through
basically
any
new
bill that may have the word animals in
it to see if it's going to affect
the humane treatment of animals
as representative sullivan indicated
we had an issue last year with the bill
that was primarily for
tracking callers and microchips but we
found an issue with the poisoning of
animals and we also were aware of
another
um statute that was in the wrong place
as far as where it was in the criminal
code
so um
we
as he mentioned he gave you the history
of it so i'm not going to go over that
again but i would like to
speak to
what's actually going on here and talk
about the pieces of the puzzle
in your handout there's a blue sheet
that
has
the
beginning of the animal cruelty act
okay and you can see that um
the definition for animal cruelty is
very broad
um and the poisoning of animals would
definitely come under that category
um
it is
gives a list it says cruelty shall
include but not be
and then goes on from there
it also defines animal
and these are very important definitions
in that law
in the 644 644-8 in the animal cruelty
law an animal is a domestic animal a
household pet or a wild animal in
captivity it's not a free living animal
it's not um wildlife
um it's much more than dogs just dogs
which is what was in the bill that was
passed last year
okay
now if you go to the actual bill
that you have
this goes on and goes down to roman
numeral three so
you've got roman numeral one in front of
you on the blue sheet we're going to
skip down to three because that's where
the germain actions are
and it talks about
a person is guilty of a misdemeanor for
a first offense and of a class b felony
for a second a subsequent offense and
then it gives you a grocery list
of
actions that somebody can take
that constitute cruelty
and you notice they all begin with the
word
negligence negligently and
representative abbas brought up the fact
that there are culpable mental
culpable
mental states
for each offense in the criminal code
there has to be a reason
for that happening so the first part of
the cruelty law
talks about negligent actions and
there's a whole bunch of them some of
them are very old terminology
but
an example is
without lawful authority negligently
deprived or causes to be private any
animal in its possession or custody
necessary care sustenance or shelter so
that's an example
so we're proposing to put
poisoning in this list
okay of the negligent offenses
and i'll talk specifically about the
language for that in a minute
now if you go down and look on line 28
roman numeral 3 a
we have another set of offenses to the
cruelty law
and these offenses are
have a higher penalty right off the bat
it's a class b felony
and that is for
individuals who purposely
commit an action against this law and
there's a
little grocery list of just five items
beats cruelly whips tortures
mutilates any animal or causes an animal
to be beaten cruelly whipped tortured or
mutilated and we'd like to add poisoning
to that list
okay so those are the basic changes we'd
like to make in the cruelty law
we feel that poisoning belongs in this
list and nowhere else in the
um statutes
now on the
back of the first sheet that i gave you
we have copies of the
laws that we're going to be
repealing so you can understand
why we had an issue with that
now the first law
is in the civil code it's under the
chapter 466 which covers dogs and cats
under the auspices of the department of
agriculture markets and food
so
it
just the second
paragraph their stealing dogs and
tampering with callers is the bill
that representative sullivan talked
about that
was passed last year
okay
and
if you look at roman numeral 2 under 466
it says
whoever distributes or exposes a
poisonous substance with the intent that
the same shall be eaten by any dog shall
be liable to the owner of the dog's
owner for its value and shall be guilty
of a class b felony
um
so first of all it's just dogs no other
animals
and it just talks about the fact that it
is
does not address a culpable mental state
that's not in there at all which is what
we need for a crime
it has only one penalty
class b felony
and it only talks about ingestion of a
poison
poison going in by mouth for the most
part okay
so
the governor's commission feels that
this should not be in the civil code it
should be part
of the criminal code and part of the
um animal cruelty law
okay if you go down and look at
another statute that's in the criminal
code 644-16
this is an old law
that's in there but it's not in the
section
where the animal related crimes are it's
someplace else off by itself
and it's called exposing poisons
and it's if any person shall in any way
or place purposely expose an active
poison or deadly substance for the
destruction of any animal
or for any other purpose except the
destruction of rats other vermin in his
own building or upon his crops he shall
be guilty of a violation
okay so that's there
um
it only talks about exposing poisons and
the penalty is only a violation which as
you know is a fine
and again the governor's commission felt
that that was not appropriate
and that it should be
um moved up to
the
animal cruelty statute which is 644.8
okay
now
we do feel
and hopefully you understand where this
is coming from that a person
that purposely tries to poison
an animal as defined under the
under the
cruelty statute which is domestic animal
household pet
or wildlife in captivity anybody that
purposely tries to poison an animal
should be guilty of a felony offense
they're doing that on purpose now it
does not cover
any wildlife doesn't cover mice rats
whatever
um
they are not covered under the animal
cruelty law
okay but somebody that's trying to
poison domestic animal household pet
or wildlife in captivity
the governor's commission feels that
that should be a felony offense
because it's intentional it's purposeful
and it's meant to harm the animal
so if we go back and look at the actual
bill again
i'd like to talk to
what we did with the language
of the cruelty law
so i'm looking at the bill i'm starting
with line 15
and i'll talk through
what each of those parts of that
two sentences mean
okay so we're adding to the misdemeanor
grocery list
that
it's a misdemeanor for first offense and
a class b felony for a second or
subsequent offense who
negligently poisons an animal by
exposing
distributing or administering an active
poison or toxic substance
causing harm or death to the animal
okay
then we try to address some of the
concerns that have been brought up here
one
and give give some exceptions
substances administered in accordance
with rsa 332 b
this happens to be the veterinary
practice act
so that if somebody
is administering a medication and the
animal has a side effect
that
that the veterinarian is absolved from
that because it's as you probably watch
tv every drug has possible side effects
okay
and then we also added
the exclusion persons using poison to
control rats and other vermin
in either their building or to protect
their crops shall be exempt from this
subparagraph
that's a direct quote from the old law
that we are
hoping to repeal um the exposing poisons
so that would absolve
your chicken coop on any of your
property
um it would allow you to do that as long
as
you were um
dealing with just vermin
now um
the definition of vermin by most
dictionaries is any of various small
animals or insects that are destructive
annoying or injurious to health
such as cockroaches and rats and so this
allows exterminators and wildlife
nuisance wildlife operators to come in
and protect your property
there's no
penalty for that
now if a neighbor's dog gets in there
that's on them
you know that's their problem it's your
property
the animal is trespassing at that point
and if they get poisoned um that's on
them
okay so that we put in the
[Music]
negligent category but we also repeated
it
down in the felony category
now um
so it's repeated under the felony
category as well
okay so those same exceptions apply
under
um
in
after line 28 when we're talking about
felony offenses in the cruelty act
okay
um
so
this bill proposes three changes that
would strengthen the current cruelty law
and remove poorly written
felony offense from the civil law
and remove an outdated statute with an
inappropriate penalty so we're doing
three things with this bill
okay so i hope i've clarified some of
the issues and questions
representatives plain
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
would you call polypropylene glycol a
toxic poison antifreeze yes so if i were
to have a spill in my driveway
so if i was to have a spill of
antifreeze polypropylene glycol in my
driveway and the dog next door came over
and licked it because it does taste
sweet
and poisoned themselves would i then be
eligible for potential prosecution under
this law because i negligently did not
clean up my spell
that's a good possibility depending on
how the investigation goes
well
if
can i continue for a minute
if it's
a question
if it's an inadvertent spill chances are
there would not be an issue if you were
um
working on your car and you knew there
was a spill
there may be an issue if you didn't
clean up
there are accidents that happen
follow up
you recognize for follow-up thank you mr
chair
would you consider chocolate toxic to
animals dogs specifically
i would follow up
mr chair
am i recognized for my follow-up yes
last one
i'll have more questions later
we generally we want to
you asked the question now you you've
changed the stuff there are a number
there are a number of issues mr chair
that need to come out on this because
there are a lot of toxic substances to
animals that
have been
now broadly categorized
in a situation where
very few people have control over them
and i would like to bring them out and
and we have a reference to an rsa down
here that applies only to veterinarians
whereas a lot of medications are now
purchasable online and or through
tractor supply down the street a plus
applicable to be administered by the
owner of the animals or livestock and
they would not be protected by this
i i understand the point that you're
making but with that point i mean this
thing going substance by substance you
could be here
that's what i was trying i'll try to put
them all together put them on how's that
thank you mr chair
would you consider chocolate onions
garlic
to all be considered toxic substances to
dogs
may i give a broad answer rather than a
specific answer
you may answer how any way you wish okay
um we're going back to the
the uh requirement of cult culpability
and it's the term negligently and it's a
growth gross deviation from conduct that
a reasonable person would observe in
that situation
if
it could be proven
that the person
administering any of those substances to
an animal
knew that they were poison you know they
would be
they would be possibly liable under this
i would say
that probably most poisoning
is inadvertent it happens
at home
by the owner and it's never going to get
reported unless it goes to
the animal gets a
very thorough evaluation by a
veterinarian determines what the toxic
substance was
it's it's not going to be an issue what
might be issues are things
like
um
golf courses using fertilizer that runs
off into
your farm's pond and your animals drink
it
things like that that are
not meant to poison the animal
but could
there's a question about having a
chicken coop so i'm referring to line
lines 18 where it says
other vermin in either the building or
to protect their crops shall be exempt
the way i interpreted that
was to not include a chicken coop
so i just didn't know if
it's not basically on on their property
would
if i may ask a follow-up thank you for
taking my question if the
term building was changed to property
would that
have any impact on the intent of this
bill
we basically
transferred the terminology from
644-16
in his own building or upon his crops he
shall be guilty
so building in
crops is
related
to
homeowners farmers
those types of things the legal question
may be is the chicken coop considered a
building so i think i just just that's a
simple fix in the drafting but the coop
itself is a building but the eggs and
feed inside it is not
okay
but i don't understand
if you're distributing
putting out rat poison or mouse poison
it's on your property
by your buildings it's to protect your
property
it's exempt from this
i think the chair was getting at the
fact that sometimes you put the poison
out not in the building or
or
directly surrounding the building but
you put it out
to deter
to the building so it could be anywhere
on your property right
representative you're recognized
thank you
thank you mr uh chair and thank you for
your testimony
if i'm reading the bill correctly now
that i understand what is new and what
is not
what basically this is going to do is if
i put out which i don't use
because i have chickens i don't use rat
poison but if i put out rat poison
in a box and a dog chewed into that
i'm not going to be held liable right
but if
a
neighbor
is sick of listening to his neighbors
dog barking 22 hours a day and he throws
poison over the fence
then that guy purposely did it and will
face these charges exactly
thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
in the line of the
bolded lines that you're talking about
it makes reference to rsa 3332 b correct
and i am it says in accordance with
rsa332b
and
it has 20 subsections to it and i'm i'm
trying to find out which one is the
right one that that it's actually
pointing to and should that in fact be
in the in
it's it's basically if it's part of a
patient-client relationship with a
veterinarian
if if if that
animal gets a hold it is
being treated for something
that turns out to be toxic for that
animal then the veterinarian is not
liable
it has to be prescribed by a
veterinarian as part of a veterinary
client relationship
representative newman you recognize for
a follow-up
i guess my follow-up is we're talking
about putting out rat traps or something
with people that are putting out
poisons that they bought
and didn't get prescribed by a
veterinarian be exempted in 332 b is
that the right place it should be or do
i just don't understand that well
if if you were you if you are using
um
insecticides for
ants or you're doing rat traps you're
for your property you're exempt
it would be an accident if your animal
got a hold of it it's not a crime
you're allowed to protect your property
i have one more follow-up
you recognize for a follow-up yeah thank
you and i i guess just the problem is
this
bill
describes
to people how they can be exempt from
that and it points directly to the to
rsa 332b
no
it's two exemptions
one for 332b and that's the veterinary
client relationship and another one if
you're protecting your property from
vermin
they're separate
but in in both
follow-up
recognize for a follow-up in both of the
places the only the only rsa i see
referenced in the law
as it's written here
is 332b and and i guess i'm probably not
asking the question right i cannot find
any language in the bill that exempts a
person who is not a veterinarian
from
from the penalty be i just can't find it
in law and i have a problem with that
okay
so it may need a definition or something
like that i i don't know but i just
cannot find something that allows me to
follow what i'm supposed to do in
accordance with it okay can't find it it
says persons using poison to control
rats and other vermin in either their
building or protect their crops shall be
exempt from this paragraph it's a direct
is that in the is that in the bill or
what are you referring to
all right
first of all i'm just going to go over
this quickly and i
feel like we do it every meeting but
we'll do it again thank you mr chair in
order for anyone to speak they need to
be recognized to speak
if as you could if you want a follow-up
question you may ask we are not
permitted to debate members of the
public we only ask questions to gather
information about the bill
clarify their testimony that that is it
any other questions will be out of order
anyone who's speaking of being
recognized i will rule them out of order
but representative newman you are
recognized for a follow-up question
thank you mr chair i don't have a
follow-up question i'm just confused and
probably will vote against
thanks thank you for the heads up
representative green you're recognized
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
what if
[Music]
a dog was
in an area where he was exposed to
either marijuana or
ingredients of marijuana
and digested those how would this be
handled
this is a not an uncommon occurrence
and
marijuana
depending on the dosage or cbd depending
on the dosage can be very toxic to
animals
now
this may happen in the home and it may
be the homeowner that's
at issue with this
so
ideally a responsible owner would take
their animal to the veterinarian
and um
the veterinarian would do a history and
figure out what happened
um it would probably go no further than
that
unless the veterinarian wanted to turn
them in
now if it's your roommate and you want
to turn them in
that's up to you because
technically a crime would have been
committed if the animal became sick or
died from it
follow up
you recognize for a follow-up
new hampshire like other states in our
area is pushing for marijuana legalizing
it
and if people starting to grow this
product
that's what i'm asking
that is that i don't i don't find that
question germane to the bill
well it would be more available whether
it's cannabis is legal for recreational
purposes or not it can still be
considered a poison just like
just like alcohol it can still be
poisonous and be
legal for recreational purposes
so we don't need to get off track on the
subject of cannabis
so i'm just wondering if we're growing
it if it does pass and we're growing it
and dogs get in there
who's going to be at fault
thank you for taking my question
i'm deeming the question out of order
and representative you are also out of
order for making the pizza comment i do
apologize
[Music]
i'll apologize to the
witness
on behalf of everyone
representative true you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking this question
i was political science not pre-med
so i i appreciate your
explanation
of why you're making changes
i understand why you wanna
why uh rsas are being repealed
i get what i don't understand ma'am is
why the new language
is being put in
i would think just by repealing
without the new language
it covers mistreatments of animals being
dogs and household pets and
it's already covered by all of that i
think maybe
that's adding to some confusion
if without it i see i see that
the poisoning would still be covered
even without these new without the the
new wording being put in is that
incorrect that that i mean if if you i
accidentally poison a dog that's gonna
that's mistreating uh
causes animals
it's
mutilated it's
it seems that the words are already
there
even if the bold letters were taken out
that's a very good question
and
probably as far as the misdemeanor
negligent offense
you are very very correct
in fact
when
i
recommend that when animals are poisoned
that law enforcement use the cruelty law
rather than the current one that we're
repealing the older one
644-16
but one of the issues is if you get down
to the
line 28
3a
if you look at that list of felony
offenses
those are words that come directly
from
up above the negligent offenses
okay
so in order for it to be a felony it's
got to be a word in there and that word
is not up above
in the fennel
in the misdemeanor offenses
so we would need to add it and then in
looking at adding it when laws are
written now we like to put in
definitions and explanations rather than
just words because those can be
misinterpreted
and that's why we put
exposing distributing or administering
an active poison or toxic substance and
why we put in the
um
exceptions
because there are instances when it
would not be
an issue
does that help you
the two representatives are having a
conversation so we wouldn't want to
interrupt
when they're done i'll recognize you for
a follow-up representative true that's
relevant to the witnesses testimony
thank you mr chan
thank you ma'am
um
i would i would say
being a political science major
that
uh
purposely
poisoning a dog is torturing that dog
if you don't kill it it's going to be
violently ill
you're causing
a severe reaction from the dog
for the dog
the dog is being tortured he may even be
torched to death
if you purposely give him poison
so that's why i'm thinking
it's already covered i just thought it
would be a lot cleaner if
repeal these rsas thank you very much
um
the governor's commission has
a lot of issues with the
terminology because it's not defined and
torture is one of those words
we have
we're aware of things that are happening
that are not covered in this bill for
for the felony offenses that we can't
that can't be proved in a court of law
if you
if you look up the word
torture you're not going to find
poisoning in there
if you look up
um
you know we have we have issues with
starvation as well because that's not in
here i mean it's
covered because they're not providing
food but it's not
a felony offense right off the bat so
there are
a lot of
missing pieces in this law that someday
we would like to correct and but that's
why we put
poisoning there thank you thank you man
thank you for your testimony
the committee now calls angela ferrari
dog owners of the granite state
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee thank you for giving me the
opportunity to testify on
hb
my name is angela ferrari i'm here
representing dog owners of the granite
state
we are an akc affiliated non-profit
organization founded in 1991 to
represent the interests of all pet
owners in new hampshire and we have a
wide variety of membership
from pet owners to breeders to various
clubs for sporting dogs etc
dog owners of the granite state opposes
this bill as written which you know
might surprise you since we do represent
the interests of dogs and their owners
however as you've had great discussion
on already
our main concern is around the use of
the word negligent and the section
f that's been added here on line 15
with so much
variety and ability for somebody to
accidentally
have
poisonous substances around that could
affect a dog
we feel that this sets up owners
friends of owners
neighbors
too much
to be pulled into this for criminal
penalty as a misdemeanor
so it's too open to interpretation i
think we've already had a lot of trouble
discussing each of the various poisons
that could be considered part of the
spill
and how that
would be considered negligent actions or
not
with the inability to
say if these different actions would
actually be considered negligent we
heard the word purposefully a lot
and that's a totally different section
of the bill and negligent versus
purposely is very different
so while we do not
support the addition of negligently
poisoning animals as part of this bill
we do understand the changes that are
being made in regards to purposeful
poisoning
and adding
poisons to
the section that starts at line 28 in
the bill
however as
raised by representative true
we do believe that the existing laws do
cover purposeful poisoning with the use
of the language that is already
in
[Music]
3a
and that goes for torturing
mutilating
and even up above
in
eye
where it says unnecessary suffering of
any kind so we feel that poison is
represented
with our current law
and
we would be okay with the two sections
being repealed and adding poison there
if you felt as a committee with your
experience in how the law is written
that it would be cleaner
reduce any confusion or remove any
loopholes that may be there with the
existing statutes
but we don't necessarily believe that it
is required
so
we would hope that you would remove the
second the section on negligent
poisoning
add poisons if you felt appropriate and
repeal those other sections or
vote the bill in expedient to legislate
and i would be happy to take any
questions
representatives plain you're recognized
i promise to behave mr chair thank you
thank you the chair for letting me ask a
question and thank you for the member
for taking my question um i appreciate
you coming here to testify today i had a
lot of concerns that you you've also
spoken to
one concern that you did not mention
is the section that only exempts
veterinarians from
administering medication do you have an
opinion on that
it was raised earlier about the ability
to purchase
veterinarian-like products from tractor
supply online other things like that
and i do think that
while we should exempt veterinarians if
they were to prescribe something that
didn't work appropriately for an animal
that we should make sure that the owner
of the animals or
owners of residences where they may
bring their dogs wouldn't be
considered negligently poisoning if
those dogs were to get into those
products
thank you
representative marston
thank you mr chairman i only have this
simple question
your association dog owners of granite
state
do they
belong to or part of
the governor's commission on human
treatment of animals yes we do have a
representative on the committee
thank you
if the chair may inquire with with a
question and uh thank you for taking my
question if the
under on line 15 where it says
negligently on the first page
would it change your
the your position of the organization's
position that was changed to perhaps
recklessly
i think i would have to think about that
and get the opinion from some of the
other members of our group
to have a better understanding of
recklessly in comparison to negligently
as my background doesn't allow me to to
answer that on the spot
it seems similar to me i'm not sure
thank you
you are you are excused thank you
the community thank you
the queen now calls kathy farley
is not my printout
one of our members is unable to attend
she's housebound at this point in time
and had some concerns
so i was just going to try to do some of
the highlights but
a lot of it majority of it has already
been covered
um but there is a you know
question she had is this bill actually
promoting pet welfare or is it just one
more burden on a pet owner facing
veterinarian bills as
you know with the poisoning
and you know the ace aspca runs an
animal poison hotline and they list the
top 10 poisons
that the uh
that are you know animals the dogs the
cats
and
you know going over them
you wouldn't think of it how many people
know that grapes are poisonous to the
dogs
how many people know that onions and
i've had i've had this scenario with a
friend of mine that
i was showing their dogs and
he didn't think of it
they had a roast beef meal
and
they put onions on top of it so they
gave him the dog the juice
into his uh food
dog ended up having uh
seizures
and you know he's
you know he's he's still alive the last
thing i knew but you know
he didn't know
and i know you'd say it's an accident
but once you know i mean
you're not going to do it are you trying
not to but how many things i've looked
at recently been looking at how many
items include
the onion you know
powder and things like that and i'm like
oh i can't give that to my dogs now you
know and things like that so
that's you know
going over the list your everyday person
is not going to know it it's going to be
an accident
they're not going to purposely do it but
trying to prove somebody it's like oh
well
your neighbor's saying you did it on
purpose and i'm like
excuse me you know i love my dogs you
know i
they're my kids
and i know that's how nancy reacts and
that's
you know the basis of her thing you know
she's she's wroting writing in today in
opposition to changes in the law
outlined in hb 1433
relative to penalties for poisoning dogs
in particular the area of negligence
when it comes to animals accidentally
ingesting toxic substances
and
you know
it turns around
and
one of the things that popped in my mind
when i
was reading this and talking about the
thinking about the poison line now are
they going to turn around
and call the state and say this person
poison their dog
yeah it's like
do they have any information whether
it's on purpose or not no they won't
they won't know you know you you
families with kids
one's eating a grape so they share it if
they've got a small dog one great can
really make that dog sick
it's you know
it's gonna be really hard as far as i'm
concerned
to follow up and put this into into play
you know i just
that's my feelings and then
on my other side
when we first got into
purebred dogs
we had
a mutt that lived i'll be honest to 21
and a half years old
i don't know how she lived because i
think she was given anything and
everything that we ate
but
we had a dopamine our very first
stovemen
that was not not even a year old
valentine's day dad gave my nice big box
of chocolates
it was up on the mantel don't ask me how
she got it but she got it down
and but she was very picky
she would take a bite out and spit it
out if she didn't like it
but
this was also a dog that always thought
you were going to poison her because she
had she did would spit out her food and
then say oh i guess i can eat it
but i mean
you got kids
that you know not they're eating
something they're going to give it to
the dog
at least i did as a as a kid so i mean
i just you know i really
go along with nancy and i
to
report this as itl
or change the bill to remove the wording
about negligence because
who's going to prove negligence
at this point in time
so
that's no
that's my say at this point i'm sorry
there being no questions thank you for
your testimony thank you
is there anyone else who's going to
testify who has not
testified there being none at this point
i'm going to close the public hearing on
hp 14-33
yeah mine too
someone stole mine wait a minute
poison dogs 2 pm
so
um
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on hb
uh 10 10 1004 relative to penalties for
failure to provide information after an
animal
injury
this bill was championed by
representative harper who cannot be here
is there someone that
you're introducing
on behalf of representative harper you
may approach
representative the floor is yours
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
i'm keith thurf representing
hillsborough district 2 where endearing
i'm substituting for representative
hopper to introduce hb004
relative to penalties for failure to
provide information after an animal
injury where's police chief moore asked
us to introduce this bill
to address a problem encountered last
year
in august 2021 at cleft state park in
ware new hampshire
a dog bit an 11 year old boy causing a
laceration which required 10 stitches
the owners of the dog and the parent of
the child
were at the scene of the incident and
observed the attack
after the attack the parent attempted to
obtain the information of the owner
who refused to provide it
and then attempted to leave the scene
police responded and were able to were
able to stop the owner
issued a citation to the owner for
violation of rsa 466
colon 31 roman numeral 2a
dogs a menace
a nuisance or vicious
officers spoke to the county attorney's
office at hillsboro north
in reference to the owner attempting to
leave the scene
but were informed there is no
requirement under existing rsas
for the owner to provide contact
information after an incident involving
an animal
the bill as introduced doesn't
adequately address all the issues raised
where chief moore wrote a proposed
amendment to the bill
i asked ols to prepare this amendment
and i hope and believe
you should have this in your possession
the proposed amendment covers
conduct and reporting after an incident
involving an animal
it is based off the requirements already
enacted
by
rsa264
colon 25
conduct and reporting after a motor
vehicle accident
that was used as a reference in
constructing the proposed amendment
my email right available okay but if
someone wants to save me the trouble and
check their email that would be
i last received an email from i can give
you her name um
if you have the amendment if you don't
just mind reporting
if i had it i would give it to you she
didn't send it to me and she said she
was sent to the committee
if the chairman quite
that i'm
well
we have
he doesn't have a cop that he can make
for you but it's what i said so i sent
both the chair and the vice chair
the copy that he's referring to that's
not the version has to be written into
law which ols prepared in sort of more
legal terms
okay
are courtney courtney s bach is that
you may go
do you want to hear from the chief in
the meantime i'm going to just sit here
and wait
you're you're excused if you if you wish
for me i want you to have questions for
me
we know what we're doing
or you can finish
no i'm done unless you
want me here thank you representative
for your testimony you're very welcome
thank you all
at this time
we recognize the chair recognizes uh
officer moore
excuse me chief moore
good afternoon i was just here to answer
any questions uh if you had any
questions about the amendment to the
bill but obviously you don't have that
yet i can read it if you'd like
if you don't mind sure
uh so what we did like i said was we
mirrored this off of conduct after an
accident if a driver fails to identify
themselves
after an accident and we use that same
methodology to apply it to this type of
incident so we titled it conduct and
reporting after an incident involving an
animal
the owner caretaker of an animal who
knows or should have known that the
animal has just been involved in any
incident which resulted in death
personal injury or damages to property
shall immediately stop at the scene of
the incident and give to any person
injured and or to the owner of any
property damaged the owner caretakers
name and address
if by reason of injury absence or
removal from the place of the incident
or other cause including a fear of
personal safety to remain at the scene
such injured person owner caretaker of
the animal or owner of the property
damaged or any of them is unable to
understand or receive the information
required in this section such
information shall be given to any
uniformed police officer arriving at the
scene of the incident or immediately to
a police officer at the nearest police
station
police officers receiving such
information and other employees of such
officers law enforcement agencies shall
be authorized to provide that
information to such injured person owner
caretaker or the authorized legal
representative
of such injured persons owners or
caretakers
if such owner caretaker of the animal is
physically or mentally incapable of
making such report the owner or
caretaker of the animal involved in such
incident or the owner caretakers
representative shall after learning of
the incident forthwith make such report
if the owner caretaker representative
fails to provide such information as
required above the owner caretaker
representative shall be guilty of a
misdemeanor
a whole lot in there
thank you for your testimony if i may
inquire with a question and thank you
for taking my question
one one of the concerns that i'm not
sure if the amendment addressed this but
it says
on line three if a dog is off leash and
injures a person
and i guess is there any reason to have
a leash requirement in order for whether
the underlying policy or the amended
policy to apply
no sir and that's why i took it out so
my background involves i was an officer
in the k-9 unit i was a supervisor in
the k-9 unit and i was the officer in
charge of the k-9 unit the one rule of
handling any animal is that animal is
under your control a leash is not needed
to demonstrate control i can give hand
and arm signals to my dog or verbal
commands and still control my animal
there are various methods of control a
leash is just one such method
if that makes sense
thank you and if i inquire with another
question if a person is bit by a dog
is there any unless you have have the
dog's information like on their call or
whatnot what's the what's the procedure
done at that time
so pretty much it's just uh exchanging
information to make we would make a
police report uh we could take criminal
action already from established rsas
this is just to ensure that the
person bit can seek
legal
ramifications for the injury through
civil court
representative rhodes thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question when this bill first came out i
actually was i'm having conversations
with representative hopper and
representative erf about
being a co-sponsor but my concern was
the very question that our chairman just
brought up about the leash
so as you have witnessed the
there are
many of us legislators have the
uncanny ability to split many hairs
over wording so
is it true that the definition off leash
in itself means not in control
or do we need does that need to change
so that doesn't say the term
off leash so the leash component was
eliminated completely from the amendment
okay as well as canine solely uh you
could have an incident with a horse
where somebody's riding down the road
the horse bucks it runs into a car car
causes several thousand damage dollars
worth of damage the owner of the horse
still has a responsibility to
identify themselves just so they can
work out some type of solution
afterwards
yes ma'am
representative pantalogist
thank you mr chairman uh
chief with the uh
you say that they didn't have to give
any information
do they give you any information
such as charts and things like that
when you make a report
are you talking about with the specific
incident yeah so dunbarton police
actually responded to that scene and
they were able to stop the owner of the
canine from leaving she was intent on
leaving without identifying herself from
that scene so we started asking the
question what if she did leave and
that's when we contacted the
hillsborough north county attorney's
office and found out there were no
repercussions if she did leave and
follow him
you're recognized um
so shouldn't there be a penalty to her
or the person leaving
because they're not saying whether those
dogs had proper shots or anything yes
ma'am that's the purpose of this um
pretty much
it makes it a misdemeanor if they leave
the scene and they don't
report to us in a very timely manner
their information and that they were
involved with this type of incident
thank
you
representative
representative rory
thank you mr chairman thank you chief
for taking my question
um i i have one small question maybe you
can put it to the rest one small concern
it says
in the amendment that um an officer or
any employee of the department shout
point of view mr mr chair i'm sorry
representative true you recognized for
your point of order i believe it is uh
please state your point of order i
believe it is customary and past
practice
for this committee not to discuss a bill
or amendment that is not before the
committee
i i have a
real problem discussing something
i know nothing about
the amendment we should not be
discussing the amendment it doesn't
exist it's not in the committee
i i do i do understand
i understand what you're saying in that
you're correct normally when we don't
really entertain especially public
testimony on an amendment unless
we're in a work session which we're not
i i did allow a little bit of uh
leeway here because the sponsor of the
bill is a member of the committee who
could not be here
today so i feel like if representative
harper was here
he would be the best person to really
i don't mean to respect him so he would
be a great person to obviously assist
the committee but he's not here so i did
allow a little bit of extra
um slack with that particular rule for
that for that reason alone but
the witness already read the what the
amendment would look like but he
actually said that's not what it would
be word for word
and
i think it's just
i understand what you're saying but
when you are correct with your point of
order so i will not permit any more
questions
relating to the amendment that we have
not received yet but
okay my question still stands because
it's it's in the original bill anyway
that a
member of law enforcement shall give the
information to the the victim of the dog
bite per se
um
so what i'm concerned with is i see a
picture of maybe a woman walking her dog
down the trail
somebody a man gets too close
maybe in an inappropriate or even
criminal way
the dog bites to protect the woman
she leaves and now this guy shows up the
police station a few hours later and
says hey this dog bit me can i get her
information and now the statute says the
police have to give that information is
there any am i am i reading too much
into that or
so that type of law already exists if
somebody was involved in an automobile
accident
as a matter of fact you have to get more
information uh in an automobile accident
we made it just with name and address so
follow-up could be obtained otherwise
how would you know who was involved
we didn't even include phone number yeah
representative you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question the uh
the bill
says that if a dog is off leash and
injures a person
responsible
provide information
so does that mean if the dog is on leash
they don't have to provide the
information
no sir it uh results in an injury again
a leash does not represent control
i had multiple bites when i was in my
canine unit some were on leash some were
off leash it was all upon my control
whether i wanted my off my canine to
bite someone
in this case if a canine bites someone
it's the failure to control the animal
and anticipate what the dog might do
which is what happened in this case
that's the responsibility of the owner
representative you recognize for a
follow-up thank you mr chair and again
thank you uh
if the dog is off leash
i don't know if that if your definition
is in
our rsas
i i think do you don't you feel a plain
reading of that
minus any definition of what off leash
is in the iosa
would mean that if he's off leash if
he's on leash it doesn't apply
so we got rid of the whole leash
component
there's three incidents types of
incidents that went forth in the
amendment
which include
if someone's injured if someone
dies from this or if there's personal uh
or there's damage to property
so if an animal has been involved in an
incident which results in death personal
injury or damage to property are now the
requirements
the control method has been eliminated
yes sir
representative green you were recognized
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
how would uh puppy be in relation to
canine in this wording how would what
puppy
in other words if somebody had a puppy
that was maybe six months old too early
to be trained
and it bit somebody
so again it's all on the result of the
incident whether somebody's injured dies
or there's property damage it doesn't
take into account the age or the ability
of the animal it's just the result of an
incident thank you
representative splain you recognized
thank you and i apologize i was running
to ols but if this has been answered
already just tell me
what if the
incident happens on my property
somebody's not supposed to be on my
property
but it's not my dog and i refuse to tell
whose dog it is
well you wouldn't be an owner a
caretaker uh where if i was watching my
son's dog and i refused to develop my
son okay so you'd be a caretaker so you
would it would be applied to this
on your own property correct
representative plane you're recognized
for a follow-up we
we have to run it very strict in here
yeah and and i apologize mr chair i
i apologize for being a little loose on
the on the follow-ups um
if it's on my own property and the
person's not supposed to be on my own
property and i refuse to tell them my
son owns the dog
i would be guilty of this crime at this
point
yes because you did not identify
yourself and where that what this is is
this just to get the information into
the judicial system so the judicial
system can take into account all the
factors of what exactly happened
representative muse
so i wanted to get your input on the
penalty
so
the penalty in this case is a
misdemeanor
a lot of our other crimes involving
animals uh are violations
um what's your opinion on that i mean as
a as a police officer one of the things
we hear a lot
is that
officers don't pay as much attention to
things that are violation level crimes
uh they're less worth their time
um
is that the purpose for
uh for the
uh for
framing this is a misdemeanor level
violation
no sir uh so one thing i preach is
circle of influence i can only affect
what i can affect
uh a violation you're talking about a
fine only
uh
if this individual is going
to not cooperate and comply with the
system and again we're going to explain
everything prior to taking action
here's what's going to happen here's
what's going to happen if you don't
provide this information it's going to
take some effort for us to finally get
that information possibly even a search
warrant so you're talking about an
enhanced effort by the police department
which was taking them away from other
community concerns because someone just
didn't want to provide information where
they were the owner of an animal and
don't want to take the appropriate
responsibility based on the actions of
the animal
yes sir
thank you for your testimony yes sir
the committee now calls
kathy farley
you're gonna wave off
okay the committee now calls angela
ferrari
good afternoon again
angela ferrari dog owners of the granite
state
i'm going to do the best that i can
without having seen the amendment
to get our concerns across so it can be
taken into account or see if it has
already been rectified
we oppose the bill as written hoping to
see some adjustments to it maybe they
are in the amendment from what i heard i
don't know that necessarily everything
was
um oh let me give out my testimony
so you can see some of our recommended
changes
when you get the testimony we had some
language in red
modifying what is in the current bill
one of our biggest concerns is around
the use of the word injury it's very
vague it could include something very
minor
so
although the amendment now doesn't focus
solely on dogs our recommended change
was
instead of injury to say
if a dog
bites a person or causes serious bodily
injury to a person
that would clarify
what an injury is so it couldn't just be
considered a scratch or some emotional
harm from a dog that was
barking aggressively at somebody that
this is actually
serious bodily injury
i will mention later in my testimony i
have a link to
the maine statute
instead of injury they've used an injury
requiring medical attention so they've
clarified that a bit further
so that could also be an appropriate
alternative to just the use of the word
injury
we also felt that knowingly the word
knowingly should be included in here
there could be a case where somebody's
dog was off leash out of sight hurt
somebody returned to the person they
went along with their day not knowing
that something did happen
so we think if the person
knows what happened and leaves the scene
then that would be more
cause for action
the last piece that we added
and i think this was covered in the
amendment because previously it didn't
mention being able to give your
information to a police officer you had
to give it directly to the person who
was injured we felt that that could put
some people
in jeopardy
or at risk and felt that it should be to
the injured person or to a police
officer as soon as possible so that they
are reporting the incident and they can
get their information to the police
rather than necessarily handing it out
to a person directly
um
one of the reasons for that is if this
is a minor they probably shouldn't be
giving their information out to just any
stranger that they've had an altercation
with and having the opportunity to
get to a safe place tell mom and dad
call the police give them the
information it can be handled properly
with an adult
the other thing and i think this might
be covered by the amendment is if for
the safety of the animal or the handler
they need to leave the scene
in a situation where
dogs are in an altercation whether it be
with a human or other dogs or what may
of
whoever has instigated the situation
with them
to be able to remove the dog and then
call the police or give your information
to the injured person
i think should be considered as well
as i mentioned maine statute
they had a similar incident where
they've recently added a new statute
that hits on this exact
situation
the link is here i will email this
testimony to you as well so you can find
it more quickly
they do mention
the requirement of medical attention
they have needing to
get local law enforcement involved
and you can take a look there but i
think either the recommendations that
have been proposed here addressing a few
of those items or how they've done it in
maine
would be a better option than i think
the direction of the amendment even goes
for this bill
and with that i would be happy to take
any questions
the chair would inquire with the
question and thank you for your
testimony and for taking my question
so one of the concerns i had when i and
i thought the motivation of this may
have been if someone's bit by a dog they
may
be curious whether they should go get a
rabies shot or not and the way to figure
that out would be
having information about the dog
but no one's brought that up yet i just
didn't know
i understand the problems with as
drafted we can't speak of the potential
of a different draft
so i guess my concern is is is that a
concern that you have about
a member of the public who's a bit by
dog and how they would go about
ascertaining that information
i would defer to law enforcement who
probably could speak more quickly about
the laws that are on the books in
regards to dogs biting
i am pretty sure that
that is why all dogs have licenses and
so that it can be looked up and if they
were able to provide their information
to law enforcement it could be confirmed
the dog does have a active or up-to-date
rabies and dog license to
alleviate any concerns around rabies
thank you for your testimony thank you
this time we will now close the public
hearing
on house bill one zero zero four
at this time the chair recognizes
excuse me this time we're now opening
the public hearing on house bill
relative to the
records
of communication calming carriers
this time the chair recognizes
representative caledon introduce
the honorable
thank you mr chairman
thank you members of the committee
this bill may look uh
vaguely familiar to you as
there was a bill h.b 539 which this
committee in the house passed
into 2001.
there it died in the senate because of
some language um
preferences by the committee um they
needed some more clarification on
what exactly would be
um the exemptions the old um bill said
it's
um
said
that
the uh communications shall ensure the
customers are kept free from
governmental intrusion into the private
and personal information by requiring
search warrant or judicially recognized
exception to the warrant before
providing information about the customer
uh its customers to a government entity
and that language
it was
criticized in the hearing as far as like
clarity and whether or not the
communication carrier would know what a
judicially recognized exception to the
warrant requirement would be
um and so uh this bill seeks to do
essentially the same thing but clarify
in
using different language so the the new
language
um
says it shall
require a valid warrant before providing
providing a government entity with
information on his customers unless it
falls under the exceptions listed under
our current rsa 644 a3
and so that that lists a bunch of things
which are already in law that people
already understand and so that would
provide more clarity
and
so
obviously the policy before this
committee
supported that
people should not be getting
be required
communication carriers should not be
required to
give out its customers information
without a search warrant being offered
just a request of the
um
the state
ag's office
and so
obviously um requiring
search warrants are
are kind of fundamental to our
our
uh protections of people's rights and so
we we definitely want to
ensure that this
practice of of getting information
without a search warrant is
limited currently it seems uh last time
i did not have the
information from the ag that responded
to my
91 a request about these requests
specifically since we had a
constitutional amendment saying that we
should be free from government intrusion
into our
private affairs and in fact what i found
was that the ag office had requested at
the time of the request at least
41 times
information about customers from people
from
facebook google
verizon
um
a whole slew of different common
carriers
of information
about their customers and these requests
generally seem to be
not from the ag
they seem to be requests from local law
enforcement requesting the information
from the ag so all of the information
was not being it was requested in those
email or in the
the demand to comply with the ag's uh
request for information it was not the
information only one time was sent back
to the ag's office all the information
was always being sent down to some local
law enforcement
agency so
that is the information that i have on
this
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
thank you
representative true you're recognized
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my my question
and you probably covered it already but
i was
not here i don't know where i was
um do you know why
they who shall not be mentioned killed
the bill
so
so i um ex
i talked about this um language
as far as
um free from government intrusion into
uh
okay um requiring a search warrant or a
judicially recognized exception to the
search warrant the senate seemed well
actually it wasn't the senate it was
communicate
consolidated communication that said we
don't know what that is
and then
the senate also
were concerned about emergency
situations like if someone's a lost
hiker or something like that that they
wanted to be able to get the um
subscriber information of their phone or
something like that and so um in this
rsa 644 a3
emergencies are one of the exceptions so
that would have addressed the issue um
obviously emergencies are are an
exception to
search warrants
now but they just wanted to have a
little bit more clarity on where the
exceptions were so that that people
could abide by the law
thank you for the question
representative follow up thank you mr
chair and thank you for taking my my
follow-up
um
i know we're not in vegas but do you
feel you have
you feel this new bill addresses
the complaints of the conservatives
yes i bel i believe that this
addresses
the concerns
of the lack of clarity in the previous
bill that the senate had and so i hope
that
you and they will be able to support it
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
the witness is excused
the committee now calls senior assistant
attorney general ben agadi from the
department of justice
thank you very much and good afternoon
everyone um i'm here from the department
of justice again uh my name is benjamin
gotti i'm a senior assistant attorney
general in the criminal justice bureau
our office is not taking a position with
regards to this bill at this time but we
wanted to make sure that we were present
so we could answer any questions that
anyone in the committee may have i've
had an opportunity to look at the bill
for a little bit do a little bit of
background research and i just stand
here ready to answer any questions
anyone may have
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
this goes to
the point i'm glad you're here
as i understand it the reason for this
bill is because lower levels
law enforcements
do not have the knowledge that they need
to get a warrant to do some of these
inquiries and they're just doing it
without a warrant which is violations
my apologies is that better i'm sorry
about that um i don't know if that they
they should know certainly that any time
that you are seeking to get content of
an individual's um account record and so
now we're talking about
again actual content of somebody's
accounts or records then they certainly
should be getting a search warrant and
that's the current standard now that all
law enforcement operates the vast
majority of the requests that we get are
from primarily from new hampshire's
internet crimes against children task
force i'd probably say 60 to 70 percent
of the ones that we do and um
a former speaker representative was
absolutely correct in terms of uh
between 2018 and 2000 2021 i believe
from januaries of those dates i believe
we did around 41 to 43 of those requests
again about 60 to 70 percent are
internet crimes against children
there's a smaller majority that are drug
cases and quite frankly i really don't
have any personal knowledge of any other
cases but it's usually a
76b subpoena that when it is issued
inevitably leads to the search warrant
being issued because
you can't get content with a 76b all you
can do i do is identify the individual
name that is attached to that particular
account or the digital phone number
that's attached to that account
the vast majority and pardon me just for
a second i know it can be long-winded
and i apologize but to explain how most
of those cases come in
it's even a process people in my office
not in the criminal bureau are not
familiar with
often we will get a cyber tip that will
come in and that will go to the icac
task force and then that goes to one of
the local catchment agencies that has an
icac officer assigned
they then contact us if they feel that
there is reasonable belief
to believe that you have a
the common communications common carrier
is being used in the commission of or
about to be or wasn't a crime and they
will ask for our assistance for a 76b
subpoena to find out
who
is registered as the owner of this ip
address
and that's i mean it's very clear in the
statute it's a very limited information
that's available
that then leads them to develop the case
to either
find that somebody may be in fact guilty
or innocent and lead to a search warrant
the only case that i can think of myself
that i've done i've been here for about
17 years
has only been one that was involved with
a homicide case and it turns out that
when we did the 76b subpoena we were
able to show that the individual ip
address was somebody that didn't have a
protected wi-fi there were 20 or 30
other residents in the building that
could have all been using their signal
so it was used really to exonerate an
individual rather than find that they're
guilty
to most address directly address the
question i think that law enforcement
should certainly know that if you want
any sort of content you have to get a
search warrant that's the law as it
stands right now
76b's are primarily used as a tool to
get the investigation started to just
say are we looking in the right area
without going into an individual's
content
thank you
welcome
thank you for testimony the chair can
inquire of a question
so thank you thank you for taking my
question
you mentioned that the term reasonable
suspicion
and
i presume it says a valid search warrant
that's
doesn't say but it's referring to
probable cause
can you exp
explain i guess that
what would what would happen if if that
standard was a probable cause
requirement as opposed to reasonable
suspicion that changed eye taxability
how much would that change in the
in the real world
in the practical sense the the court
does draw a distinction between
reasonable suspicion and probable cause
and that's been standard both when you
look at this from a federal
constitutional rights that we all have
or the rights that we have under the new
hampshire constitution um there so the
court does draw some distinction but
what's uh great about many judicial
decisions is of course it doesn't say
exactly what that distinction is so
you're still looking at it being whether
it is more reasonable or not or the
court will say is it more probable none
and each time the court will always say
we will use a totality of the
circumstances test we will look at all
of the circumstances when we know and
find whether it's again either more
reasonable or more probable
but better that i can't really define
what that standard is better than that
because the court won't define what that
standard is better than that
representative muse
thank you for taking my question as a
practical matter when it comes to these
investigations
to what extent would it be an additional
burden on the attorney general's office
to have to go through
a a process of securing a warrant for
this
for this type of information is this
not a big deal are there time issues
involved
is there a problem
i would answer that by saying that there
are certainly some time issues that are
naturally going to be involved in that
process um so to give everybody kind of
an understanding of what time issues
look like now
when one of those cyber tips comes in
and it gets to the right investigator
who then says this could have grounds
for a 76b let's find out who this ip
address is
that phone call can be made and we can
probably after we review it because
again there does have to be that
reasonable suspicion that it's there and
we have to check that before we even
think about writing one of these up
you're looking at a process that may
take an hour or two a search warrant
process is naturally going to be a
little bit longer you have to be able to
submit the search warrant you're also
going to have to it also depends on the
time of day
an assistant attorney general is usually
available 24 7 for law enforcement all
they have to do is usually call one of
our cell phones in order to do a search
warrant instead
if it's daytime in superior court where
most of these offenses
crimes against children child
pornography drug offenses most of those
are felonies so they have to be in
superior court that's pulling a judge
off the bench to be able to make that
decision or trying to get the nighttime
judge
you have less control over what the
timeline of that would be
and with most of the icac references
that we get there's a question of
whether or not there's a child that is
currently or in the immediate past in
danger and that's one of the other
reasons why when you ask about delay
there would be some delay that would
come with regards to doing a search
warrant
but again it would not have content so
you can't get any content with these
representative muse recognized for
follow-up
just a quick follow-up um
in cases like this
how important is it to act
uh
quickly
versus
acting
with confidence that you're
basically dotting all the i's and
crossing all the t's
i would say the second one is more
important it's crossing the t's and are
dying in the eyes and crossing the t's
that's more important there has to be
for example one one of these comes in
each one of us in our office
writes up a memo that's that's kept
in-house
that understands what the facts were for
us to have a basis to be able to issue
this letter um
i think one thing that many people don't
understand about prosecutors whether
it's in our office or county-wide is to
say we actually say no a lot more than
we say yes
and here um
it's more important to make sure that
you have it right just as much as
finding the guilty protecting the
innocent um
having it right is more important than
expediency
one final follow-up
and would you say that having a warrant
in this situation would help you do that
more effectively
i think having a warrant in this
situation it depends on the material
that we have um i think here you have a
standard that yes you're looking at here
for reasonable suspicion that the the
communications common carrier has been
used in the commission of a crime um
it's often
most of these will lead to a warrant
once you're seeking an individual's
content
it has to be that way it's the right
thing to do in that case
but in that balance of time and crossing
the t's and dotting the eyes
having the appropriate medium between
meeting both of those needs 76bs
currently
tends to do that but certainly when it
comes to the icat cases
thank you
representative newman you recognized
thank you you may have mentioned this in
your testimony i haven't picked it up
or understood it completely
um this the way this law is written it
repeals a section and then uh and then
reenacts it as written and it makes it
very difficult to understand the
difference between
the reinstruct the uh
the reenacted language and the language
that was appealed could you just briefly
comment on on what effect this has
as a replacement thank you
certainly i'm
sorry let me just make him try by the
statute with me
essentially
if you look at the two side by side
you can read through subsections
i believe it's we're looking at roman
one sections a through f are are
identical
between the two statutes so essentially
it it takes the current law of what's in
place that would allow this written
administrative subpoena process
and it
stops that it ceases it and so for those
same sets of information that currently
an administrative subpoena would be
available for now it must be done via
search warrant under what's proposed
representative newman are you recognized
not knowing the difference between a
search warrant and an administrative
warrant is one simpler one easier one
more effective one less effective or how
what what
do you have any comments about that
um sure an administrative warrant when
it's issued from our office is uh very
very simple it's a it's a document that
would come out let's say on letterhead
it would be signed by an authorized and
trained assistant attorney general there
is a training process that they have to
go through
not just every attorney in my office has
the ability to issue these they have to
know again what they're looking for be
able to appropriately write
the in-house memo and say that they can
find that reasonable suspicion is there
the process of issuing that it looks
almost like a letter
it's puts the statute in it and so that
the receiving company understands what
it is
a search warrant on the other hand
you're going to require a submission of
an affidavit that has to get written by
the investigator not by an attorney
that then needs to be submitted to the
court there is a whole process to do
that both in the district and superior
court usually with an application that
comes in potentially also with the
motion to seal with regards to the
nature of the investigation
and then that has to get approved by the
court they will issue
the warrant it's a one-page document
that comes out signed and certified and
then eventually a return has to be filed
with the court so administrative
subpoena is essentially a two-page
document that would come out of our
office looks a lot like a letter
a warrant itself would involve a
submission of a multiple page affidavit
to the court a warrant application a
warrant that issues and then a return
that has to get filed back with the
court once the company provides the
information i hope that answers the
question
representative newman recognized for a
follow-up
thank you for the follow-up
um so
those two things they both have the same
do they do they both have the same
effect that you can start your
investigation and get the same type of
information as a result of either one of
those right now
they will not not right now because this
isn't enacted yet
so if i just want to make sure if i can
clarify that i'm understanding the
question correctly so that
can
can the same information be obtained
under the current standard versus the
proposed change
thank you
um
yeah you gave a description about what
you get from from using this with the
search warrant and you could start an
investigation and you explained a lot of
things to it
with an
administrative warrant could you also
get that same information or is it
lesser less information do you get a
more information is there what's the
difference between the two i understand
i understand um there's a there's a very
large difference between what's
available now under the statute versus
if you were to choose to do a search
warrant right now
warrant
for example
and i did bring an example with me a
matter that was submitted to our office
just last in in september
where
facebook alerted us that there were two
images of underage children that they
believed violated child pornography laws
here in new hampshire
for us
once that cyber tip comes in
we could now under the statute as it is
written
do an administrative subpoena to find
out
the registered name or the email address
that goes along with that facebook page
and then the investigation could start
from there we would be very limited in
what we were able to find out we would
be able to find out
specifically
the email address that they've used to
create that account a phone number that
they use to create that account
and that is essentially it if it was a
phone number reporting we could find out
um the name of the person that owns the
phone number or the ip address that's
all that's really available under the
current 76b
if we were to do a search warrant right
now for that let's say we that would
allow us to now
obtain
copies of everything that's in that
person's facebook account look at the
photos look at their text messages look
at their posts potentially as long as
reasonably tied to what we believe is
the infraction that's occurred the crime
that's occurred
if you were to seek to get into the
facebook and we believe these two photos
are there a search warrant would allow
us to go in look at the facebook see if
those two photos are there and find out
discussions back and forth about those
photos we couldn't willy nilly grab
everything that's there that wouldn't be
proper because we don't have probable
cause to believe that the other things
on that page are evidence of a crime we
can only go in and get what's evidence
of a crime but we could not get any sort
of content we can't right now under the
76b law as it's written only to find out
who the individual is
and then that would have to lead to more
investigation to possibly get a search
warrant which
many of them do
thank you
representative true you recognized
thank you mr chan
thank you for my uh for taking my
question
with the bill becoming law let's
assume that the communications carry is
not liable for giving you
my given the ag
my personal information
what if
a local
law enforcement agency
said uh called up say hey zucky it's
your old roommate can you give me the
information and they give them
my information
uh my name
no not me him
my name my address they give all this
stuff out
because they you know he's calling in a
favor or whatever
what's the penalty
for them doing that
so in in an action like that and and i
can only speak to it from my own
standpoint of being a prosecutor so if
that case were to come to me and i find
out that the local law enforcement
officer did not properly get if assuming
that this change were to go through if
you choose to do that
and they did not get a search warrant
for it most likely what that means is
that any evidence that was gathered as a
result of that the information that he
learned
and the fruit of the poisonous tree
doctrine which would be any information
he learns from that information
would be
suppressed we would not be able to use
that at trial
representative true you're recognized
for a follow-up thank you mr chair thank
you again
um
yes
so
but
i can't say my good name is first
because i've been charged with a
horrible climb but that information is
now out
in my town that's the guy
they didn't do anything to him
but everyone knows i'm the guy
would
would you bring a communications
company to court would you
would i have to
sue oh i see you mean for the for
if there wasn't a protection that was
written into the statue
um
whether or not uh that is something that
the ag's office would pursue
unfortunately that's going to be
something outside of my bail wick that's
going to be upstairs in the civil bureau
that's going to be much better to be
able to answer that um
as i as i frequently say to a lot of
victims families that i might work with
there's always a difference between i
don't know and i can't tell you and this
is an answer well i don't know that
would have to be a decision probably
made by the civil bureau thank you
representative muse
thank you
thanks for taking my question again so
to to to basically try to sum up part of
this conversation and i want to make
sure i'm summing it up accurately
but
the current process is for you to obtain
an administrative warrant
which is fairly easy for your office to
do fairly easy for your office to get
a search warrant though would have a a
much wider scope
so particu so one of the things that
occurs to me and and
i'd appreciate you just letting me know
if this is true or nada
because a search warrant has a much
wider scope
there's potential for a lot more
personal information to be found and
disclosed through that process correct
that's correct the 76b as it's written
and
and when i say as it's written or if you
choose to adopt this when we're looking
at that that subsections a through f
that those pieces of information are
very what we would consider very very
simple business records um that a person
has chosen to sign up with facebook or
chosen to sign up
with verizon and have service
that is
again very basic business record
information
no
real private information and no content
is available through
the seven six seven six b process as
it's written now um and it would change
to get that stuff now you have to go
through a search warrant and if this
change were enacted that would still be
true you would still have to go and get
through a search warrant so for example
you and i think this might best answer
the questions
things that are not available under a
76b right now
you would not be able to find out when a
person logged onto or off of the service
you would not be able to find out the
websites that they visited using that
service you couldn't find out who they
emailed you could not find out who
emailed them
you couldn't find any sort of content of
their communications
none of that is available through the
76b process right now the only way to
get that is through a subpoena if you
make this particular change uh
that still will be true you will still
have to get i'm sorry search warrant you
will still have to get a search warrant
to get that content
thank you
representative newman
and just one final question about
administrative versus search warrants
yes sir
if this bill passes as written
will you still have the capability that
you have in the
current law that says upon written
demand of the attorney et cetera et
cetera et cetera
both of those things be
available to you or would this require
that they all be done by search warrants
um as i am reading through this proposal
effectively what it would mean is that
this same information that is currently
again 16 to 18 times a year that are
used through an administrative subpoena
would now be required to have a search
warrant done instead and so law
enforcement would have to seek a search
warrant for that same information
thank you
representative splain
yes
thank you for taking my question
if i'm understanding this appropriately
the extent of information you can get
off an administrative request right now
is extremely limited
you can essentially tell that somebody
used a service
and what ip they used it from
that's correct you can't tell any of the
other information that they've done over
that service when they've logged in or
out
any of the other information
if you've determined
that they've used the service
you would need to now get a search
warrant to find the specific information
that you think was
negligent or criminal in their use of
the service is that correct that's
absolutely correct
so in essence oh follow-up
thank you
i'm sorry for slacking on that again um
in essence
all this bill would be doing is taking
out the preliminary step where you you
verify that the person used the service
and had an ip address that came from
their computer
yes because you would have to go
directly to the warrant process
you would have to go directly to the
warrant process what it would do it was
it would change the method in which that
information was gathered instead of
the phone call and establishment and the
issuance of an administrative 76b
subpoena you would go through a warrant
process instead
and you would have to do that in order
to obtain that same information that's
correct thank you
thank you for your testimony
thank you
the public hearing on hb 1282 is now
closed
and we will
be exacting some bills
so
[Music]
five minute recess
back and say david get that yeah
i know
for two
now
at at this time
at this time
i'm gonna go very slow
here
at this time we we're now opening the
executive session on house bill 1571
increasing fines for littering and
directing revenues to the fish and game
department
this
this time the chair recognized represent
representative conley to make a motion i
would move itl on hb 1571. most of nxp
into legislate is there a second
that has been seconded by representative
burt
you wish to speak
representative burt
it's a bad bill
well said
representative lang as the chairman of
fish a gay committee i agree it's a bad
bill
representative martin you wish to add
anything to that discussion
yes
i have a question if i may
you
may you may speak
we you heard all the testimony and i
was unfortunate not to be here can i get
i had originally thought this bill
should be enough to pass
in my note-taking at home i'm just
wondering why are you people thinking
this is a bad bill
i mean it gives revenue to the fish and
game and it also increases the fines for
people littering and to me
that kind of makes some sense so where
is the problem in this bill for me to
vote with you i'll start with answering
that by i was also not here for the
hearing so i didn't hear
i didn't hear the testimony that was
presented to the committee but from what
i understand that this would this would
have a set a cost of 75 000
it's not clear that the
fines would actually
uh account for that revenue but it also
has been brought to my attention that
there is another
bill that's in the transportation
committee that addresses littering
that may find its way to this committee
is it's a little
less of a fiscal impact as this version
so that's just my own
opinion
but i wasn't here for the hearing so i
can't thank you for that explanation may
i ask may i do a follow-up to the
gentleman from fish and game
an explanation as to why it's a bad bill
sure absolutely so again while fish and
game is
a self-funding agency
this starts drawing from other areas of
our of our um citizens that hasn't been
vetted yet so for lack of a better
phrase was we're starting to add
we'll use the example of a 500 fine
which has a 20 20 penalty assessment
which which makes it the six hundred
dollar fine which then another twenty
percent penalty assessment proficient
game which now makes it a six hundred
and
seven hundred and twenty dollar fine so
i think it's poorly thought out the
whole idea of twenty percent is a number
that no one's quite sure what it means
thank you tim
representative
representative wallace
thank you mr chairman also attorney head
from the department of justice said this
is going to net about 5 000 a year in
new revenue
and with a 75 000 implementation cost
that's a net negative of 69 000 bucks
that's a big no
in 15 years it would take to
recover that
at this time that matter will not be put
to question if you
if you're in support of the motion of
inexp and to legislate
please say
yes if you oppose please say name the
clerk and i'll call the role
vice chairman roy yes
representative lying yes representative
burt
yes representative rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes
representative spelaine
yes representative true
yay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative pantalakis yes
representative tallersky
yes
representative bordenay yes
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman yes
representative bolden
representative conley
yes
representative sue newman yes
representative bradley
yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
and one not voting
twenty zero i move
i move for
consent so moved
representative will you be preparing the
majority report
thank you
at this time the
executive session uh we'll now close the
exec executive session house bill 15
1571.
at this time we'll now open the
executive session on house bill 1175
relative to the recording interactions
with public officials
the chair recognizes representative
bradley to make a motion
thank you chair i make a motion to itl
hb 1175
that's been seconded by representative
pantalakis
representative bradley you wish to speak
to your motion
i do um i think earlier representative
rhodes said it
better than i think
any of us could um she addressed the
seriousness of
being able to videotape inside a public
school
where parents at this time do have a
choice of whether to opt out their
children from photographs or videos
and this just
will put those children and many other
children at risk
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman
i think that this bill is written has
several gross unintended consequences
and
while i do recognize
that people have the right
to record public employees i also
recognize the right that public
employees have a right to privacy
so there was testimony given today that
if you are in a room that is labeled
private
but yet you are let's say a boss of an
organization that's a public entity
if if another employee is in that room
having a conversation what if this
conversation
involves the employees health what if
they need to take a a family time leave
for a private matter
that is an unintended consequence of
this bill
furthermore
we had discussion about recording in
schools so what i fear is going to
happen next is we're going to have to
have a law
that says well now they lawfully need
access to
the school because they're allowed to
record these teachers and that is where
we're getting into issue with kids
i'm able to protect myself i will
protect myself but when you start
talking about my child or somebody's
else's child that is off limits
thank you mr chairman
representative roy
thank you mr chairman i actually was a
co-sponsor of this bill um
and um
i was for it
until the
witness testimony and they talked me out
of it so
um
i support the itl
thank you now i have to apologize not
here for this hearing was that witness
in support of this bill or an opposition
uh the witness was in support of the
bill
that's that's interesting to know
representative true
thank you mr chair
government must be open and accessible
students are not part of government
but
teachers and coaches
and uh
zoning board members and planning board
members who aren't paid
they're part of government
uh recording public officials
doing their public job
there's
nothing to be hidden from the public
there
because
the constitution says government must be
open
and accountable to the people
so i can't support the itl
thank you mr chair
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
i too was not here for the hearing and
i originally was saying maybe ought to
pass in my notes
i guess i'm somewhat with chris true
representative true
in that we need to know and there
shouldn't be any reason why somebody
shouldn't be recorded in their official
capacity i understand that politicians
have a right to privacy but not a right
to privacy when they're doing their
official business
and i don't know but do we now have a
situation where you can record officials
like policemen and stuff
so
the courts have
ruled on this rather consistently that
any public official
is your for the most part
i mean there's time place and manner
restrictions but you can you can record
a police officer who's acting within
their official capacity you as long as
you don't obstruct what they're doing
you're free to you that's the first
amendment and even in some circumstances
a fourth amendment
uh issue so you're you're allowed to do
that already this was trying to make an
attempt to codify
basically you know different supreme
court cases from all different states
and the supreme court united states i
think the concern that was brought up
and someone who was here please correct
me if i'm wrong
is that an individual with perhaps a
known
criminal background
can go on school property and because a
teacher could be considered a public
official because their
employee of government
could be recorded by this individual
with the criminal record and that crime
can even involve
crimes against children
but nonetheless
they can do under this if they they're
going to say well i have a first
amendment right to do this i want to
record the teacher oh it just happens to
be an elementary school classroom i'm
just explaining in that scenario that's
the concern of some of the unintended
consequences if you're in a public space
if someone's in here a member of the
public and they start recording us
they're allowed to even and i hope this
doesn't start happening but if i'm at a
restaurant even
what am i going to do my protection is
not the first amendment it's the
restaurant to help me out and say hey
can you have them stop but as a public
figure with some we sign off we sign off
on that but a teacher
teaching a classroom who's trying to
educate children having a
that scenario
arise it's a concern and i think
i think the bill is well intended i
don't think i certainly don't think that
was the intended of the sponsors who put
the bill forward but
unintended consequences it may have
representative marston
thank you again mr chairman
the example as i understand it is a
criminal going into a classroom
most schools are secure you have to be
buzzed in you have to have a reason for
being there you have you got to cease
you get stopped you just don't walk in
like you did 20 30 years ago so and
again a criminal gonna do this i don't
think they got the brains to figure out
to do that but again i'm along with
chris true representative true and i
think this bill should ought to pass and
i will vote against the itl thank you
representative burke
thank you mr chairman uh i too will be
supporting the bill uh i have supported
this for many years i've talked to the
aclu about putting in a bill
to do away even with one consent party
because the states that don't have it
which are the majority of the states
there's only a few states that are like
us where you have to have to consent
and it's easier to
catch
you know the uh
town worker the state worker that's
misbehaving
or an elected official
uh you know with the video and audio
of a recording
of their misdoings
i just
you know i just look at you know the
government must be recorded at all times
you know if i had my way about it every
one of them would wear a body cam and
then we'd have access to that body cam
now when they're off duty
absolutely they have a right to privacy
but if they're at a grocery store
you know that's a public place anybody
can come up and film me people have
taken pictures of me at stores
um
you know not often but a few
and you know i just was hoping it was
because of my looks but you know bottom
line
you know people can do
in public
they still can do this
and when it comes to schools i mean i i
think you you know that you know people
are just looking way too much into that
um i don't see how that can happen out
of this bill
uh because bottom line a classroom is a
private classroom
with those students in the teacher and i
don't see how this bill would allow
somebody to say i have a right to go in
there
now if it's a parent talking to the
teacher you know after school absolutely
that parent has the right to videotape
that
and um
you know it's just
you know we you know eventually we'll
get there but we have to pass something
and sadly it doesn't look like this is
going to be the bill so hopefully at
some point you know they'll redefine
you know what is
allowed
but you know right now you know
throughout the courts you know we can
finally videotape police and i know on
where they arrested six people for
videotaping their own traffic stop with
the police and luckily ended up down
into a federal court and
massachusetts and you know because all
of our courts kept saying yeah you can
charge them for wiretapping and finally
the court down there said you can't so
that's all this bill was going to do was
to codify what the federal court already
says we have a right to do
and so hopefully we'll keep pushing
toward it thank you
representative newman
thank you mr chair um
i am not i'm going to support the itl
and the primary reason is is just the
way the
the law
is or the proposed law is written
and especially because of the
the confusion over definitions of things
like in a pub in in public what exactly
does that mean
and um
so
it seems to me that
with the public
you can have a public building
but there are private spaces in that
public building i i after the
hearing i talked to one of the people
who testified and
what i heard and i agreed with was that
a public space is probably where the
people can come in and out of here and
go as they please in a school they can't
go in and out of there as they please
but that's not defined this way so that
people can easily understand what this
will be
so i think an amendment might be able to
improve this bill i don't know
but for right now the way it's written
now i'll support an idea
representative pantologis
that this bill is too far region
and we have boards that are water boards
or
uh
recreational boards that are considered
as officials in that area
and that they would be
able to be
recorded when they might not even know
that this law exists
i mean i just don't think that this
world has gone so far that every time
somebody speaks they have to be recorded
thank you
representative
i i do want to say that i'm i'm
i'm very sympathetic with the people who
put the full the bill forward because i
do think that as public officials we
have an obligation uh to be transparent
and to be cooperative
when constituents or anybody else asks
us questions about what we're doing
um but
the issues i the issue i have is how we
define public officials
so are we defining public officials or
as people who are
elected to office or appointed to office
do they include every classified
employee
who works for any government agent you
know it works for government really at
any level at all
and
and separating
you know
in an age when a lot of people are
working virtually and a lot of people
are working at home and not everybody
goes to an office um it becomes very
very difficult to sort of separate
um
you know
what your work life is from your
personal life and and i think that
if we pass if we pass this as written
um one of the things that we're doing is
in an effort to create more transparency
we're really opening the doors to some
really really critical violations of of
privacy
um and also just people's well-being um
who needs to be followed around with a
camera who needs to worry about having
to shut the blinds of their house i mean
that one guy was test testified the the
only time we shouldn't be available to
people is like when we're in our homes
uh and when we have the blinds closed i
mean
you know so i mean that gives you an
idea how some people might interpret
something like this and i think that's
why i'm going to vote for the itl
representative roy
thank you
as i said earlier i i was one of the
sponsors and i believe that there there
is absolutely um room where where some
recording of public officials can happen
and should happen and people should be
able to do but i also want us to look at
the humanity of it
um
right now i go to the landfill every
saturday
uh one of the guys at the landfill i i
love
chatting with him i almost said shooting
something um chatting with him and he'll
give me some of the local gossip and
it's just one of the places you go and
you hang out and you talk and he's good
well i don't want people like that to
worry that every time they talk to
someone
they have to we're all going to turn
into robots we're going to give the
minimal answers we're not going to
engage on a personal level like
constituents because you never know
who's recording you who's trying to
who's trying to trap you i mean it's
just it's going to turn us all into a
bunch of robots
now there's some like i said there's
some situations such as with law
enforcement or if you walk into an
official's office and it's already an
official interaction but when you can be
recorded
at any time or place and it turns into a
game of gotcha and you just can't be
friends with your constituents anymore
or friendly with people you don't know
it's just not a world i want to live in
so i wouldn't support something so broad
representative bourdain
thank you mr chair
i'm going to support the ito abortion
um
on first reading of the bill it seems to
be a good bill something that we could
all support we all believe in
the public needs to have access to
public meetings
um
but unfortunately the way this
bill is written
and could be interpreted
there are ramifications that
are
we don't know exactly what it is
and so is a little broader than we need
what
i would suggest is the sponsors of this
bill
take a
a much narrower view of
what
what should be recorded
and i think public meetings uh are
probably the place to start right now i
don't think we have uh
legislation that that allows all public
meetings to be recorded though in this
day and age it seems like all our public
meetings are being broadcast
and we also maybe want to look at
making certain that
our citizens and our law enforcement
people
understand that any interactions of
them with the public as far as traffic
stops
are
recordable
and
i would be
more than willing to support such
legislation in the future
but i am really opposed to this
particular bill thank you
representative eric arthroid
while we were in that meeting um
yeah while we're in the meeting
um bradley did um research because we
were concerned about what was public
place
and in in the statute says any place to
which the public or substantial group
has access the term includes but is not
limited to public ways sidewalks schools
hospitals government offices or
facilities and the lobbies or hallways
of apartment buildings dormitories
hotels or motels
he also said please note that this
definition was found in rsa 644 colon 2
which addresses disorderly conduct
i think i was appalled when i think it
was one of
i don't know what town he's from but
one of the representatives said that
if i was
in a restaurant with my son or my child
and i was talking politics to them and
someone is recording me i don't think i
would have felt comfortable about that
and it really did hit home because quite
often i'm with my grandchildren and
they're for always asking questions and
i'm always talking about what happens
you know so
for me i think that's an overreach
into my private life especially
and if it didn't matter whether i was
off duty at that point because i'm not
doing
state business
right at that point i'm on my own time
with my my grandchild or my children
so with all that said
i tell
representative splain
thank you mr chair
i liked the concept of this bill
i liked the ability for
a family specifically
because of the research i've done into
the dcyf situation a family that that
had a dcyf person coming in for an
interview to be able to record that
person in the
process of their job inside their own
home
but i had a problem with the fact that
it said in public
because their home is not public there's
a problem with the bill in that aspect
i think that yes we should be able to
record police officers in the course of
their duty when they're in public
arresting people or even if they're in
private in your private home you have a
right to record them in the process of
the duties but like others i feel that
there's an
uh a great
expansion here of what is intended
and i would have rather seen this bill
go to interim study to fix it
but i'll support the itl if that's the
way the committee is going because i
think that there's a future for this and
there's a need for this especially with
the situations we've seen
with the need to record police and dcyf
and other things
but at this point this bill is not ready
representative true
thank you mr chair either this probably
just a question of the chair or just a
clarification
of what i believe i heard you say
in your given your opinion earlier
that
the supreme court has already stated
public officials
during the performance of their duties
may be recorded
and that
the supreme court did not have any
difficulty understanding what public
officials meant
nor do they have any difficulty in
deciding what performance of their
duties meant
and with that
all this bill does
is put into new hampshire law
what the supreme court has ruled in
cases
i think that's an oversimplification of
what i was trying to say but they you
are no one right now under current law
you know the representatives um
using the example if you're in the
privacy of your own home can you record
someone if you have a home security
system as long as you post a notice
that's how you get consent it's a with
this if you look at it um
rsa 570 a colon 2 that a lot of that has
to do with the two-party consent
and whether the other party is okay with
being recorded and then there's
exceptions to when you don't need that
person's consent
being a public official in a public
place there are you do have a right to
record the person but
it's it when you have a first amendment
right you can't just
say whatever you want there's certain
things are definition of speech
from what i understand that this is
being interpreted too broadly where
there is no exception you would be
allowed to record a public official
provide their own public any any type of
public place without any exception
whatsoever so this is taking what i
would say the supreme court ruled and
even expanding that
and and i think what it's expanding it
to
is what are the some of the unintended
consequences that a lot of members had
concerns with i don't if someone is here
filming us
it's their right and under the first
amendment they're allowed to do it and
no one no one would argue otherwise but
by codifying this and keep in mind the
supreme court united states makes it
makes a decision
but we
and representative harrick gathered read
this
as at the state level have a definition
of public officials in public property
so that's where it can be the language
we can mix and match your words and
create confusion that's why the
unintended consequences is what a lot of
the concern people have with the bill is
this my concern is
we may respond to whatever
um and
pre-med not pre-law but
could you give us the supreme court case
where they stated that public officials
may be
recorded
during the performance of their duties
so that we could have a chance to read
that supreme court ruling
off the top of my head i can't but it
involved the
similar law in massachusetts whereas a
student was filming
police officers arrest her her friend
and she was also then
got in trouble apparently for recording
the police officers and the argument was
well
she didn't have our consent to record us
and the supreme court said
no you were in public you're a police
officer you were performing an arrest
she had a first amendment right to
record that because what she believed
was sincerely a fourth amendment
violation an unlawful arrest regardless
of what the arrest of was lawful the
court said in that scenario they said as
applied in that circumstance
that was unconstitutional because she
had a right to record that's not a new
hampshire law i thank you for that
maybe a rough idea with a year so i'd
have a chance of finding it i think it's
2012. my memory is correct
so i'm pretty sure it's someone you know
chris it's carla geralic's case when she
was recording the where police officers
i believe it was um so it's someone you
even know you can go have a conversation
with her she took it all the way to the
supreme court because she was charged
with wiretapping and then she ended up
taking all the way to the supreme court
and the supreme court ruled that you
have the right to
to film a police officer in a
performance of his duties and you don't
need their consent because they're in
the actions of doing their public job
if i could just say one more thing
thank you so the second thing i'd say
chris is what are you off duty
when you're off duty as a state
representative
when is a police officer off duty
right
i'd say a police officer is off duty
when he's off shift
uh the police officer goes back on duty
if he's going to click claim the right
as a police officer to
stop a crime
now now he's acting as in his official
capacity
he's not on the clock there but he just
went became an official
representative of the police uh so the
unfortunate thing as a police officer
you're on duty 24 hours a day
you have the you have the authority and
the responsibility to act and so you
have
almost in any circumstance of this law
to go in effect you have no privacy
anywhere you go because a police officer
has that authority and they they have an
obligation to act
um
so again i i think this this law is a
little bit too broad a little bit too
vague um you know
again i go back to the conversation when
are you off duty how many conversations
you have about politics when you're at
home you're in a restaurant you're in a
grocery store someone comes up and says
hey what happened to this bill
and the question is do you want us a
camera in your face every time you're
just having a private conversation with
a citizen citizen about updating them on
whatever the information was
do you want a camera in your face i i
think that that's you know it's it
it causes problems and to not over
confuse the issue when we say public
officials if you're a public figure a
celebrity an actress or a famous author
they go out in public and they're
constantly confronted by other members
of the public want to take a picture
with them or the paparazzi follows them
around and even that's protected by the
first amendment when they're sitting in
a restaurant just having a cup of coffee
and all of a sudden people just start
taking their pictures
so celebrities go through the same thing
as well but we're talking about kids in
a classroom here and a teacher teaching
a class and all the concern is is that
the bill as drafted
would go too far no one's no one's
trying to trample the first amendment
here
i i don't think that's a fair
interpretation because as has been
mentioned before you can say i want to
protect my children but the school
protects your children by not allowing
you to walk into the school you can't
say well those kids were being filmed by
this
whoever he was this mr unknown
what the principal just buzzed through
go walk around all you want that doesn't
happen so it's an unfair
characterization that it's about the
students
when that can't happen
representative marston
thank you mr chairman i just want to
point out to the committee it
specifically says
when you are in the process of
performing his or her duties
when you're in a restaurant you're not
performing your duties you're feeding
your belly and you are not to be then
recorded
but i i don't understand why you have
such a problem
there's a time and a place to record
officials doing their official duties
such as the police arresting somebody
and so on and so forth there are times
and places when we do not should not be
allowing somebody to photograph or take
videos of you when you're in a
restaurant or when you read your family
out shopping that's that's ludicrous
who's doing that i just want to point
out
i just wanted to remind the community i
wasn't here for the public hearing so
so if if someone wants to summarize what
what was perhaps said in a short
concise
representative right you were you at the
time acting as chair of the committee
perhaps you would like to
summarize the concerning
the the the sponsor of the bill was was
entirely reasonable um the the other the
supporter of the bill was not quite so
much
um
and he was here recording us as he did
it which is right
um
but when explaining what he would do
with the bill
um
he would record what did he say
yes
sorry he said that he would remove the
section where it says
in the process of performing his or her
duties it should be done at any time and
anywhere
yeah
i'm telling you what he was recommending
an amendment for yeah
and it wasn't uh to clarify the school
issue there was never any talk about
adults being able to walk into schools
what the discussion was was a student in
the school wanting to videotape their
teacher
and well in the process of doing that if
the kid is five rows back he's gonna
catch the first five rules of other
students in that recording whose parents
have not given permission and his
response to that was well if you don't
like that take your kid to a private
school
um
and that's just entirely inappropriate
what good does it have a policy in a
school where you cannot
take images of students without the
parent's permission to just let
anyone take videos and put it out on the
internet for anyone to see and someone
advocating for that frankly with a with
a criminal record of inappropriate
conduct with children is just beyond the
pale
having said that i still think there is
reasonable ground to be had in it but
this is not the vehicle to do it
so just to summarize that testimony that
i was not here for
is it fair to say that
if a teacher was with their classroom on
a field trip on
some nature trail somewhere in a public
place
that individual although
recording the teacher may
inadvertently record the students as
well would be within their grounds to do
so
yes if the if the teacher has taken the
kids to a public park
people in that public park can record
anyone they want there's no expectation
of privacy in a public park
thank you
and thank you representative for
summarizing the testimony
representative splain
thank you mr chair one of the other
areas that they talked about that sort
of had blurred lines was the expectation
of privacy and uh
it it pained me to hear the testimony of
the young child who got
some of his school years taken away by
recording something at school or
recording the police interaction and
then getting penalized at school and
having his homework locked down and
everything because
there was a reason there was no
reasonable expectation of privacy for
police arresting someone on the street
but
again i think that we've gone beyond the
police situation and i would point out
uh as well that it was the supreme court
case in 2014 of frasier versus evans
that codified the recording of the
police
we've gone beyond police here though
at this time now
well now move the when i'll move the
question
if you're in support
of the motion of art
and expedient to legislate
please say yes if you're opposed
please say no
clerk would not call the roll
vice chairman roy yes representative
lang
yes representative burt
no
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative spelaine
yes
representative true
no representative pratt
yes
representative marston
no
representative harriet gathright
representative pantalakis yes
representative talarsky yes
representative bourdain yes
representative news
yes
representative ray newman
representative bolden
representative connolly
yes
representative sue newman yes
representative bradley yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
17 years
three nays one not voting
there's one absent
i get
by a vote of 17 years
three nays and one not voting
the motion passes
anyone wish to move move for consent
i don't believe there's any sense in
going on consent
will it be a minority report yes
there will be a majority report
it will not be on consent
at this time we will now close the
executive session on house bill 1175
this time we're not going to open the
executive session on house bill
1282 relative to
the records of communication common
carriers
before i recognize anyone for
to make any type of motion
as i was saying before i recognize
anyone to make a motion
all she did was miss the world before
she missed but knowing my friend from
nashua would never
never disrupt anything like that on
purpose
but before we get to that uh
there was a bill we had last year
i believe it was hb 569.
i i supported the bill in this room
i went
to the i spoke on well not
we're in the sports arena i spoke at the
sports arena in support of the motion of
ought to pass
it passed in the house
went to the
other body that we shall not mention
where it was itled or whatever version
they have of that
it's our understanding and
representative roy
inquired with the clerk
not not the cl not the clerk for the
house the clerk in the body that we
shall not mention
that are they allowed to hear this in
the first place actually take this issue
up
and
my understanding of that conversation
the answer is no
similar to where if we
in the house were to
find something in expedia to legislate
if the same bill or a similar one like
that were to come back
even if we even if we change our mind
and like it i'm not sure we're allowed
to
act on it so
with that being said
as much as i may want to
show some support for the bill that was
filed
if i might ask the chair a question
you're so recognized has the senate
clerk
read the bill to determine if it's
substantially different or not
since it has not been yet introduced
into the senate
representative roy you may be the better
person to answer that
i gave the uh
the
voldemort clerk
the uh bill numbers but i did not
actually give him the like give her the
language but
she gave me a copy
of the rule
and it clearly said that it's similar to
ours if it's it held its itl they can't
come back
thank you mr chair well um
i had this conversation with the prime
sponsor the representative from fremont
and his words to me was that the bill
had been substantially changed and
addressed some of the confusion that it
created in this in the other body
and to that end
i think we ought to give this bill a
chance
and ols
should have caught that and shouldn't
have allowed it to proceed if that was
the case that it was
that much if it was that similar so
i'm of the opinion to
pass this out a committee send it over
to the other body
and let the decision be made at that
point
and let me just clarify
to the determination of whether a bill
is substantially similar or not is not
something as the chair i'm allowed to
make that determination
so i don't make that determination it's
just something to keep in mind
but if the clerk
made that
suggestion and
it just it may be an idea where it's
going it doesn't again that's nothing to
do with the policy of the bill it's just
something to keep in mind
if i may and it's my understanding that
in our body the speaker of the house
determines whether or not something is
germane or not not the clerk of the
court that being said
the clerk of the other body doesn't have
that role that would be the senate
president would it not
without being an expert on the rules but
if if it's parallel to that of the house
correct thank you but may i read the
rule
it's short yes
general rules on bills 3-2-1
prohibition in second year session no
bill or resolution the subject matter of
which has been indefinitely postponed or
made inexpedient to legislate
in the other place in the
in the first year session shall be
admitted into the second year session
whether as a bill an amendment a
committee of conference report or in any
other manner
question mr chair
representative marston you've been
recognized
the question that i have is
that i'm confused about what you're
saying this bill
was previously
passed in our house and went to the
other body
well which is it yes and no is what i'm
hearing
that clears it right up yes
hb5
is it
539 so hb 539
was the bill we had last year
the language is not word for word the
same exact
draft
so
can i finish answering the question
that i'm in the middle of before i
inquire take another one
so it's not the same word for word
but it doesn't what
i think a
plain reading of the rule is that if
it's on the same topic subject matter
which this
involves how the st the
state
government gets records
from common carriers by getting a
warrant
the last fight hp 539 was that same
issue
how does the
attorney general of the state get
records from uh communication common
carriers
and
what that would have done 539 would have
increased it to a probable cause
standard as opposed to reasonable
suspicion
and my support for that was well what if
the communication common carrier didn't
want to provide the information
some of some of these companies pride
themselves on protecting our information
not just freely handing it over to the
government when it's asked for
so
i thought that
i thought there was nothing wrong with a
probable cause standard
but
this what this is doing it doesn't say
probable cause but it's it's the same
thing it's making it
you get a valid search warrant
before before the records could be
turned over which is a probable cause
standard to get a search warrant so this
is i'm just saying that to me it's the
same subject matter now again we don't
make that
representative wallace is correct that's
for this
president of the body we shall not
speak of to make
i really don't like that rule that we
can't just
say we can't say we can't just say
what's going on with the title but
anyway
i think it's the same exact thing it
covers the same subject matter it even
has the same
it's the same purpose it's just written
in the dif it's written differently but
it's the same thing
the chair
uh i heard that there was a it was
question of the chair
i heard a motion to uh on this bill but
i did not hear a second
no one was recognized for a motion uh
to put salt in the moon
if there is no emotion on the floor then
what are we discussing i'm just i was
just discussing that
issue before i recognized someone for i
just wanted to know
thank you and then it turned into a very
in-depth discussion that i would
representative catherine
i do wish to be recognized for a motion
i'd like to make a motion to itl this
bill thank you
second
that has been seconded by representative
pantologist
representative you're recognized for
your point of order i believe it is
customary and uh uh
customary in this to announce the bill
that we're getting ready to vote on and
i have not heard any announcement of
whatever bill i'm supposed to be talking
about
you
thank you for your point of order i
heard a motion to this bill
well
i are you saying that the way the
representative
did because they didn't say the bill
number
i guess what i guess what i'm saying is
if the motion is to itl this bill that
is an improper motion
can't itl make a move to itl
this bill what bill well we are in the
middle of an executive session for house
bill 1282.
so i although i don't i i'm not sure
what the representative said if if the
representative did say this bill during
an executive session
on hb 1282 i would assume they were
referring to hp 1282. i didn't even hear
that we called an executive session on
1282.
we are
i did not hear that called
i understand
excuse me um
representative roy did you
understand
the senate rule to say that they would
not accept it
the senate did not tell me they would
not accept it they sent me a copy of the
rule after i sent them the bill numbers
and i understand the bill number to be
that this is the same
um exact wording of the of the rules
subject matter
regardless of how we tweaked it it's the
same subject matter they wouldn't be
able to take it up but
having said that this body is free to
make whatever recommendation it wishes
thank you that that doesn't necessarily
yeah and just because they won't accept
it doesn't mean it should necessarily
affect what you're going to do just
throw it out there to people
representative burt
thank you mr chairman
in the 12 years i've been here we have
never
itl the bill
because the other body
may not bring it up
because the only person that i know of
as you pointed out that can say yes this
language is the same is the speaker of
the house
huh
or the senate president
so it just disturbs me that we are
acting on a rule
from the senate
so with that said i you know i like the
bill i'm going to support it uh because
as they said you know between 2018 um
the ag dude guy
2018 to 2021 41 to 43
requests
were used
under this program
to get information even minimal
information
without a warrant
and
you know he wouldn't he wouldn't answer
the question which i think was asked a
couple times
how long does it take
well he would tell you how long it takes
to get this under this program you know
the 41 to 43 times if that's an accurate
number
of
how quick that is
but he never answered how quick he he
could do a um
a warrant and i wanted to know that
because
that is the way it should be we must
have warrants you know and you know 60
percent of it he says is for
you know um
you know children again you know crimes
against children so
you know yes we need to hurry up and
find out that information
if that's the case
but there's still laws that we should
follow and if this is a loophole or
whatever it is that they use or maybe
it's a law that they use
um this program that they talked that
number
um you know we got to have
warrants for all of this
and
again you know it just disturbs me that
we are acting on what the other body is
going to do or their rules
um when the speaker should be
determining if this is different because
bottom line it's not different i looked
up
a minute yup
you were recognized for your point of
order please take your point of order
uh usually when before we start
debate with other members we offer
the
person who offered the motion the
opportunity to speak and i have not
heard that person speak yet
i can wait
no i can start over later
so i'm not i'm not clear the rules
actually say but i i apologize i think
when she when the representative made
the motion there was a point of order
and i may not have gone back to the
representative and i apologize to that
but if it's all possible i suppose that
is a rule that i did not follow
would the representative from goffstown
be permitted at least finish his
dialogue before
representing
harry catherine can speak
[Laughter]
but but you you may be actually correct
i'm just i didn't mean any disrespect
but i just would prefer him to
please finish his sentence
do you would drive the point of order
i will draw the point of water thank you
all right and
the reality of it is i don't even have
to say anything but i'm going to say
something since you brought that to the
attention of everyone
um
i thought he was finished i'm sorry no
thank you
so i think my last thoughts were
you know the speaker needs to make the
determination because when i look back
at house bill 539 yes the
intent is the same but the words are
different
because what i look at is we v we
itl a lot of marijuana bills
then we pass some marijuana bills the
intent is the same it's to legalize
marijuana
but the language is a little different
so that's why i am looking at this going
no
no i'm going to uh go against the itl
and support a another motion if that's
gets to that point
and you know because we do this all the
time we vote bills down
of the same topic and support other
bills of the same topic
that's why i want the speaker to see
this bill to determine if it's germaine
or not thank you
and just to clarify the
whether this is
a similar subject matter would be for
the not even for the house to decide it
would be
the others so
representative herrick that's right
i'll say it again
um i'm making a motion
to itl
hb 1282.
um
i listen to this
testimony
benjamin giddy i think his name was from
the department of justice and when he
talked about most of these crimes were
60 to 70 percent of intimate internet
crimes against children
which is a big puppy of mine um
and certain things have to happen almost
immediately
um i have to respect that because
anything that you do against children in
my in my opinion um
we need to act on immediately but he
also said that we also have these laws
already it's in terms of warrants and he
talked about two different type of
warrants not quite that i really
understood them but one was
administrative and the other one was
more on a search type basis but he said
they had to get uh
i think one was through superior court
and the other warrant was through
the attorney assistant attorney general
so these things are really already in
place
so with that said right now i don't
believe that this bill is
ready for prime time
and i've also heard and know about the
bill from
last term 539
so with that said again
i wish to itl this bill
representative newman
i just want to
say that i agree with the explanation
that was just given they have these
administrative subpoenas i believe is
what they call them and then they have
the search warrant they have the option
of either or
and i believe the timeliness thing is a
factor
and therefore
i don't really care what body did
something to what other body with this
bill i'm just talking about what the
substance of the bill is and i think
they should have both options thank you
representative muse
i actually wrote the the minority report
and voted against this bill the last
time and one of the main reasons i did
that was because the only person who
came and testified in support of it was
the sponsor
and i really did want to hear from
someone in the attorney general's office
what the implications would be of
passing this bill
and you know the bottom line is it just
doesn't seem to do much um
you know it would create uh
it would essentially force the attorney
general's office to go through some
additional process work but one of the
things that we're talking about here is
you know with an administrative warrant
what he's out what they're after
initially isn't you know and he said
this he says we're not after your after
personal information we're not after
your you know the internet sites you
visited those are all things that we
have to get a search warrant to find
but basically what they are is they're
trying to match an ip address that they
have
you know on internet child porn
with ip addresses that the uh that the
carrier would have
and if once you get a match then
what he was saying is we go for the
search warrant
so so to me it seems like the invest
like the administrative procedure that
they have right now is proper it allows
them to
to get the information they need pretty
quickly uh and then if it's going to go
any farther they need to get a warrant
for it so i'm i'm a little stuck on why
we would need the bill which is why i'm
going to vote against it
representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking oh no um
so
uh
we passed a similar bill
um
last year
now this committee is not bound by what
this committee did last year i realized
that however
in reading the
corrections from
the changes from the bill that we
thought was okay last year
this bill now becomes an even better
okay bill this year
what this bill
the way i read it is telling the
the attorney general office
that we have a constitutional right
to our privacy
and if they want to start poking their
nose into our privacy they must have a
search warrant
not an administrative form
they must have a search warrant and if
they can get that search warrant
then i my privacy
is going to be looked into because they
have probable cause they have the search
warrant
this is just a better bill
that was a good bill
last year
that said
all i know is
the speaker of the house
decides
and has already decided because he sent
this bill to our committee
he's already decided that this is a good
this is a a proper bill
um
and why wouldn't he because we passed it
last year or a similar bill last year
and therefore we can pass a similar bill
this year
what
what the senate may or may not do
has no bearing on how i will vote or a
reason why i will vote for or against
the bill
did i say that word i meant they who
shall not be mentioned
because i don't care what they might do
tomorrow doesn't affect whether we've
got a good bill today
thank you mr chair
thank you and i do agree with the
constitutional side because if the
communication common carry does not want
to comply with these this administrative
request the fourth amendment says
probable cause i don't understand
what the what's going on here i is i
understand there's a public
reason for
i'm not saying the the
witness from the attorney general's
office didn't make good points on what
they're trying to accomplish but the
fourth amendment says probable cause so
if the communication common carry does
not want to participate
or voluntarily
you know cooperate with said
investigation
i'm not sure why there's no probable
cause standard there i i don't know that
was my speech on the
for the whole house
but it didn't
apparently didn't work very well in the
other
body
i just
represents plain
thank you mr chair
i agree with
representative muse on
a lot of his
discussion of where this goes
the administrative warrant from my
understanding and from what he said only
allows them to get
did they access this and what ip address
was linked to it then they got to go get
the regular warrant
so i don't see where passing this bill
causes a problem
because
if they get the warrant in the first
place they get all the information
and they don't have to deal with the
administrative warrant or administrative
uh subpoena request
and it protects the fourth amendment
rights
and and it protects our constitutional
rights to privacy of data
so if unless someone has not had an
opportunity to speak this do they wish
to speak otherwise i think at this point
we're going to move the question
about to move the question yeah i
understand that so the question for us
is an itl however if we don't itl and we
choose to otp it it could go
either the speaker could rule it as as
void or it could go to the senate and
the senate would really like one regret
i have is bringing up any kind of
complicated i'm trying to do this
outside the community trying to
understand what we're doing if what the
implications are and
the issue it wouldn't even be in in the
house it would be what happened if it
passes the house would they be be able
to act on it i can representative true
is correct that that has no bearing on
this committee whatsoever the policy is
really what we should be deciding
um so although i believe
that this anyone who reads this is going
to find that the material substantially
similar and therefore make that said
ruling i am not the one that makes that
ruling i have no influence over that
person to make the ruling
and with that being said i think the
point was being made should that
influence how
we vote in here today i think we're
about to find out if i can move the
question so this time
uh
matter now we put the question if you
support the motion of index being to
legislate please say yes if you're
opposed please say no
vice chairman roy
no
representative lange
representative burke
no
representative rhodes
representative greene
no
clerk votes no representative spelaine
representative true nay
representative pratt no
representative marston
nay
representative harriet gathright yes
representative pantalakis yes
representative talarsky yes
representative bordenay no
representative muse
yes
representative ray newman
no
representative bolden
representative conley
no
representative sue newman
representative bradley no
jim and abbas
the chair votes no
15 nays
five yays
one not voting
motion fails
after that the chairman i recognized
representative roy to make a motion
i would like to move on to pass
second
has been seconded by representative
wallace
and
just so i don't make that same mistake
again representative roy do you wish to
speak to your motion
no
this time the
matter
the matter where now we put the question
if you in support of the motion of ought
to pass
house bill 1282 please say
yes if you were opposed
please say no
clerk would not call the roll
why are you getting caught up i
apologize for creating some confusion
with the
the rules
okay on the motion of otp on house bill
1282 vice chairman roy yes
representative lang
yes
representative burt
yes representative rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative spelaine
yes representative true yay
representative pratt
yes
representative marston yay
representative harriet gathright
representative pantalakis no
representative talersky no
representative bordenay
yes
news
no
representative ray newman
representative bolden representative
conley
yes
representative sue newman
no
representative bradley yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
14 yays 6a one not voting
motion passes
on a positive note you can probably use
the majority report from from
last last year
and recycle that
in representative music you wrote a
minority report on a similar bill
last year so i assume you can recycle
that as well so would you be preparing
me not quite but but i'll figure out a
different uh a different angle on it
this time
this time we'll now close the executive
session on house bill 1282
um
we're not going to execute anything else
today but just so some members can get a
head start
there is a
prepared amendment on hb 1108 and
33.
i would make sure everyone has a copy of
that before they go
it should be making its way around
it's right here
and this time the
criminal justice public safety committee
will be
adjourned
is 1108 coming this way is
you